la parole est à Madame Danielle auonau
rapporteur de la commission des lois
constitutionnelles législation
etadministration générale de la
République pour 10
[Applaudissements]
minutes
merci présidente ministre
collègues les services publics sont
notre patrimoine collectif ils sont le
produit de lutte et conquête sociale de
la réol française au Conseil national de
la Résistance il structure tous les pans
de notre vie répondent à nos besoins
fondamentaux contribu à la cohésion
sociale et territoriale ainsi qu'à
l'égalisation des conditions d'existence
c'est la République en acte les services
publics sont aussi notre futur les
renforcer et les développer est une
nécessité absolue pour faire face au
défi civilisationnel que représente le
dérèglement climatique au cours des
dernières décennies ils ont connu
d'importantes évolutions en lien avec
cell des besoins sociaux qui ont
transformé les attentes de la population
parmi les virages importants marquant de
l'action publique qui ont eu lieu
l'introduction des technologies
numériques et la numérisation des
procédures administratives répondent son
contexte sans contexte aux exigences de
mode de vie contemporain ces
transformations ont été accueillies
positivement par une majorité de la
population en effet les outils numérique
sont porteurs de progrès dans de
nombreux domaines par contre lorsqu'ell
participe de politique de restruction
budgétaire et s'accompagne du recul des
implantations territoriales la
numérisation des services publics
conduit à des ruptures d'accès au droits
pour une part non négligeable de la
population notamment pour les personnes
les plus précaires qui sont confrontées
aux démarches les plus complexes dans le
quotidien des habitants et habitantes
fonctionnaires bénévoles et salariés des
associations que j'ai rencontré aux
quatre coin de la France au cours des 6
derniers mois à Paris auosser Lure
Toulouse au man à à fortcalquier
Marseille safré Tarbe Pamier villeurbane
et vaau envelin Nanterre lî et roubet
àour et au-delà cette dématérialisation
se traduit trop souvent par des portes
closes des boîtes vocales saturées
l'impossibilité d'obtenir un rendez-vous
physique des délais de traitement
déraisonnable et la quasi obligation de
passer par le numérique la coordinatrice
de l'association Ziva nanter le résume
ainsi on parle de dématérialisation moi
je parle de déshumanisation du système
on ne met plus personne devant les gens
on les laisse se débrouiller avec des
moyens auxquels ils n'ont pas
accès ce constat est aujourd'hui
largement documenté en premier lieu par
la Défenseur des droits qui a réalisé un
travail de suivi des effets de la
dématérialisation des procédures
administratives entre 20199 et 2022 dans
ces deux études l'autorité
administrative indépendante pointe la
gravité de la situation alertant sur la
rupture d'accès au droit pour des
millions d'usagères et usagers rupture
pour toutes celles et ceux qui n' NT pas
les moyens de se procurer le matériel et
les accès nécessaires quand c'est bouffé
ou accéder à Internet les mamans elles
choisit de donner à manger à leurs
enfants nous rapportait une animatrice
du comité du quartier aroubet rupture
encore pour toutes celles et ceux dont
la capacité à survivre dépend d'une
décision administrative qui tarde et sur
laquelle elle et î n'ont aucune prise je
suis à la retraite depuis décembre 2022
j'ai fait ma demande 3 mois en avance et
je n'ai toujours pas de réponse souvent
c'est très difficile de se nourrir et
surtout de payer loyer témoignage d'un
retraité devant la Caisse nationale
d'assurance vieillesse de Paris rupture
toujours pour celles et ceux pour qui
les démarches numérique sont un obstacle
parfois insurmontable en particulier les
personnes en situation de précarité les
sites c'est délicat difficile il faut
cocher taper là pour voir si je ne suis
pas un robot d'où je peux imaginer que
quelqu'un va prendre ma place pour
toucher
492,64 € par mois demandait un
bénéficiaire du Secours catholique en
avril dernier les travaux récents sur
les phénomène d'exclusion numérique
estime à 13 millions le nombre de
personnes en difficulté avec le
numérique en France un panel très large
de personnes sont concernés les
personnes en situation de handicap pour
qui les sites et applications sont loin
d'être toujours adapté les personnes
étrangères qui ne maîtrisent pas
toujours la langue ni la culture
administrative de notre pays pour les
personnes âgées les difficultés
importantes rencontrées avec les
démarches des matérialisé se traduit
souvent par une perte d'autonomie elle
qui arrivit à se débrouiller toute seule
dépend désormais de la présence de leurs
enfants ou proches les jeunes sont
également moins à l'aise qu'on ne le
croit avec l'administration
dématérialisée un/4 des 1824 ans
indiqués en 2020 avoir rencontré des
difficultés pour réaliser seul des
démarches en ligne soit 14 points de
plus que la moyenne des centres urbains
ultra denensifiés aux campagnes
désertifié la dématérialisation à à
marche forcée met à mal les fondements
mêmees du service public continuité
égalité adaptitéap stabilité sont les
trois grands principes sensés les guider
mais quelle continuité quand les usagers
et les usagères se retrouvent face au
guichet fermé de la Caisse nationale
d'assurance malavie ou quand elle et il
on moins d'une chance sur deux d'obtenir
une réponse à leur appel téléphonique à
la CAF quelle égalité quand 22 % de la
population ne dispose ni d'un ordinateur
ni d'une tablette à domicile et 15 % n'a
pas de connexion Internet quelle
adaptabilité quand c'est désormais à
l'usager ou à l'usagère de se substituer
à l'administration et de trouver les
moyens de se former de se faire aider de
faire ou d'être capable cette situation
n'est pas une erreur système mais le
résultat de choix politique le logiciel
néolibéral du New public management a
fait du numérique depuis maintenant 30
ans un outil de démantelllement de
désorganisation et de réduction des
services publics sous couvert de
modernisation il s'agit d'appliquer une
logique de rationalisation et de
réduction du champ de l'État social si
la dématérialisation ne permet ne
permettait pas d'économie de coût de
gestion elle ne serait pas présenté
comme moderne résumait un sociologue
lors de nos auditions la les
suppressions de postes lors de la
révision générale des politique publique
et la réforme de l'administration
territoriale de l'État sous Nicolas
Sarkozi ont été suivies par celles liées
à la modernisation de l'action publique
de François Hollande aujourd'hui la
politique d'Emmanuel Macron se poursuit
dans la même veine selon la Cour des
comptes les effectifs de
l'administration territoriale de l'État
sont ainsi passé de
82429 équivalents temps plein annuel
travaillés à 60
666 entre 2012 et 2020 soit une
réduction de 14 %. sur le terrain les
dans les administration si les agents et
les agentes sentent bien l'impact
négatif de ces réductions de postes elle
et il peine à voir les gains de
productivité sur leur travail quotidien
les guiget ferment certes mais les
dossiers eux continuent de s'empiler
c'est ce que nous ont rapporté les
agents et les agentes chargés de
l'indemnisation à Pôle Emploi
Île-de-France chez qui une baisse de la
charge de travail importante avait été
anticipée du fait de la
dématérialisation l'automatisation et
l'externalisation de certaines tâches
entre 2015 et 2018 elle était planifiée
de l'ordre de 39 %. par contre il
n'avait pas été envisagé qu'à défaut de
se rendre au guichet les usagers et
usagères passeraient en plus grand
nombre par les canaux numériques et
téléphoniques résultat plus 287 % sur
les flux de mail indemnisation plus 157
% sur les flux téléphoniques entrant et
plus 1227 % sur les sortants Paul emploi
assurance maladie préfecture CAF
finances publiques retraite répression
des fraudes la liste des services
publics où les agentes et les agents
sonnent la lart est un indicateur de
l'ampleur du problème partout
elle et il font état des mêmes
situations surcharge de travail perte de
sens manque de formation augmentation du
stress et des burnout de l'autre côté du
guichet dématérialisé l'éloignement des
usagers et des usagères approfondi des
fractures sociales déjà béantes
l'augmentation des nonreours la casi
impossibilité de contester une
suspension des droits ou encore
l'augmentation des délais de traitement
accroissent les difficultés financières
sanitaires ou professionnels des usagers
et usagères qui sont déjà les plus
précaires par ce désengagement l'état
envoie comme message aux citoyens et
citoyennes
autoadministrez-vous ce sont de fait les
réseaux de solidarité qui prennent le
relais famille amis association
travailleurs et travailleuses social le
report se fait ainsi en cascade les
administrations au porteclose renvoient
vers des structures sociales locales
elle-même débordée et en manque de
personnel elle renvoie vers des
structures associatives à bout de
souffle et en incapacité de répondre à
toutes les demandes des personnels du
service public à la Défenseur des droits
des associations de consommateurs et
consommatrices au collectifs de citoyens
et citoyennes tout le monde alerte sur
la nécessité de maintenir une double
entrée dans les services publics une
exigence entendue par le Conseil d'État
le 3 juin 2022 au sujet de l'imposition
du numérique en matière de titre de
séjour il estimait indispensable qu'une
voie alternative à la dématérialisation
reste ouverte un an plus tard dans un
rapport annuel il alerte solennellement
sur le fossé qui s'est créé entre
l'action publique et les usagers par la
création des 2600 guichets uniques de
proximité dans les espace France service
le gouvernement reconnaît lui-même les
nombreux trous dans la raquette créé par
la dématérialisation tousasimu et
confirme le bien fondé de notre
proposition de loi les acteurs et
actrices de terrain le disent sans
embage les Fran servic c'est mieux avec
que 100 tous et toutes saluent là
précisément le retour de lieux d'accueil
physique dans les territoires qui on qui
en ont été cruellement privés le
dispositif devra néanmoins se renforcer
significativement notamment en terme de
financement de dimensionnement et
d'implantation pour pouvoir répondre aux
besoins de premier niveau qu'il vise par
contre il n'est pas pensé pour les cas
les plus complexes qui nécessitent
l'expertise des techniciens et
techniciennes spécialisés des différents
organismes concernés pour ces derniers
comme pour les espaces France service
notre proposition de loi permettrait
justement de garantir le principe d'un
accueil et d'un accompagnement physique
des usagers et usagères tout au long de
leur démarche ce que propose ce texte ce
n'est pas un retour en arrière mais une
avancée par la reconnaissance et le
renforcement des droits de tous et
toutes 91 % des Français et Françaises y
sont favorables ainsi en votant pour
cette proposition de loi collègues nous
répondront au besoins fondamentaux de la
population et feront aussi œuvre utile
d'intérêt général
madame la
rapporteur la parole est à Madame
Sabrina AGR roubage secrétaire d'État
chargé de la citoyenneté et de la
ville
alors
madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur nous allons donc examiner ce
soir votre proposition de loi tendant à
la réouverture des accueils physiques
dans les services public si de prime à
bord l'objectif est entendable vos
moyens pour y parvenir et ceux qu'il
sous-entendent vont à l'encontre de la
stratégie déployée depuis
2017 vous avez là une lecture
particulière très éloigné de la
situation du terrain non le numérique
n'est pas à opposer à l'accueil physique
accueil physique
téléphone site internet application
smartphone c'est autant de manière
d'accomplir ces démarches
administratives qu'il faut proposer à
l'usagers sans exclure l'un au profit de
l'autre avec une attention particulière
au guichet physique pour aider ceux qui
en ont le plus besoin ah bah je suis là
pour ça ça j'avais compris
non la création d'un guichet dès lors
qu'une démarche est possible par voie
dématérialisée n'est pas n'est pas une
bonne idée surtout si ce n'est pas ce
que les français demandent quoi qu'on en
dise non les maisons Fran service ne
sont pas des coquivid je vous invite à
vous y rendre avec moi ou avec le
ministre et à interroger des centaines
de milliers de Français qui s'y rendent
chaque
mois oui j'aurai l'occasion de revenir
sur ces trois points mais je profite de
cette introduction
pour vous indiquer que le gouvernement
ne soutiendra pas ce texte le numérique
n'est pas l'ennemi des services publics
votre texte cite le chiffre de 20 % des
Français éloignés du numérique mais
cette catégorie recouvre des situations
très variées qui vont de personnes en
situation réelle d'incapacité à utiliser
les services numériques jusqu'aux
personnes qui se retrouvent à un instant
donné bloqué par le dysfonctionnement
d'une
démarche contrairement à ce que voudrait
à ce que voudrez une vision simpliste de
la situation nous avons autant de
réponses qu'il y a de situations
différentes dans ces 20 % la stratégie
du gouvernement en la matière est simple
continuer à dématérialiser pour rendre
les Français qui le souhaitent
autonomees dans leur démarche en
veillant à la qualité des services
numériques et consacrer plus de temps de
ressources et d'agents au service de
ceux qui en ont le plus besoin c'est
pénible contrairement à ce qu'avance la
proposition de loi tous les agés ne sont
pas déboussolés par la possibilité de
pouvoir choisir le canal qui leur
correspond le mieux que ce soit le canal
téléphonique le canal numérique ou le
canal physique comme comme l'a rappelé
la première ministre lors du dernier
comité interministériel de la
transformation publique l'objectif n'est
pas d'opposer le numérique et l'accueil
physique aujourd'hui de plus en plus de
Français utilisent le numérique aussi
parce que nous cessons d'améliorer les
démarches en ligne ligne depuis le début
de l'année il y a eu près de 700
millions de visites sur le sur le site
Internet
service-publ.fr nous avons dématérialisé
94 % de ces 250 alors s'il vous plaît
seulle madame la ministre a la parole
merci renoncer à rendre nos démarches
accessibles en ligne serait un retour en
arrière net pour la grande majorité des
Français qui
privilégie que vous le vouliz ou non le
canal numérique pour entrer en relation
avec l'administration et faire leur
démarche c'est je crois le cas d'un
grand nombre de parlementaires ici
présents mesdames et messieurs les
députés en il y en a pas beaucoup là
nous continuerons donc
à à dématérialiser nos démarches mais en
accélérant notamment sur trois aspects
pour lesquels le ministre Stanislas
Guerini est engagé premier point E
oui devine l'accessibilité aux personnes
en situation de handicap sur laquelle
des des engagements forts ont été pris
par le Président de la République et se
traduisent par un effort financier de 60
millions d'euros sur 5 ans qui devront
permettre de rendre les 250 démarches
les plus utilisé accessibles aux
personnes en situation de handicap d'ici
à 2025 cet effort se traduit également
par le renforcement du régime de
sanctions désormais confié à l'arcom et
qui prévoit des sanctions pouvant aller
jusqu'à 50000 € pour le non respect des
exigences
d'accessibilité 2è point la simplicité
du langage et la qualité des interfaces
parce qu'un langage trop administratif
peut freiner l'accès aux démarches en
ligne il y a au sein de la direction du
numérique des commandos expérience
usager constitué d'experts en conception
qui ont déjà réalisé plus de 200
accompagnements simplifiés des démarches
en ligne depuis 2020 3è point la
meilleure circulation des données
initiées par le déploiement de France
Connect qui a permis 40 millions à 40
millions de Français de facil
l'enregistrement sur les démarches en
ligne nous poursuivons cette logique
avec le principe du dites-le nous une
fois ce principe de pré de préremplir
les
formulaires évite au français non ça
c'est ce que vous croyez au français de
de fournir des justificatifs dans la
dans l'administration dispose déjà par
ailleurs le ministre a souhaité se
saisir des perspectives couvre le
développement technologique et
l'intelligence artificielle il y a pour
cela il a pour cela lancé une
expérimentation Ia auprès de 1000 agents
pour les accompagner dans la rédaction
des réponses en ligne aux usagers grâce
à la numérisation les agents gagnent du
temps et se consacrent donc davantage au
contact avec les usagers qui en ont le
plus besoin un exemple très concret pour
l'Agence nationale des titres sécurité
il lui fallait 13 jours en moyenne pour
répondre avant le débat de
l'expérimentation contre 2 jours
aujourd'hui avec des réponses de
meilleure qualité vous le voyez le
numérique ne veut pas dire absence
d'humain mais complémentarité le
numérique est aussi au service de
l'humain le numérique permet de se
libérer du temps pour que nos agents le
consacrent aux Français qui souhaitent
être davantage
accompagnés sur la relation à l'usager
et à la veille idée que représente
France service l'accueil physique reste
au cœur de notre stratégie mais nous
l'articulons intelligemment avec le
contact le téléphone et internet cette
proposition de
témoine de votre méconnaissance de la
manière dont les usagers accèdent au
servicees public plutôt que d'opposer
physique et numérique il faut penser
parcours
usager on peut très bien commencer sa
démarche en ligne ou au téléphone avec
avant de se rendre dans un guichet pour
l'achever je veux d'ailleurs insister
sur le téléphone que vous oubliez un peu
trop vite cela reste un canal essentiel
d'accès au services publ et nous avons
lancé un plan téléphone à l'aété pour
améliorer le service rendu dans nos
administ tion et chez nos opérateurs il
commence à porter ses fruits notamment
avec l'introduction de nouvelles
fonctionnalités pour l'usager comme la
possibilité d'être rappelé par un agent
cela permet de mieux prendre en compte
les contraintes des usagers je pense ici
aux seniors et aux personnes en
situation de handicap qui se déplacent
moins facilement et sont moins à l'aise
avec internet cette notion de parcours
de l'usager le Gouvernement a souhaité
qu'elle soit au cœur de la réflexion de
nos administrations pour améliorer la
qualité de service elle se déploie
notamment dans la simplification de 10
démarches clé nommé les moments de vie
cela va du décès d'un proche au départ à
l'étranger en passant par le fait de
devenir étudiant là les Frans services
sont les nouveaux visages des services
publics enfin Madame la rapporteur
concernant les maisons franc servic vous
reprenez une situation une citation du
président de la République pour nous
expliquer que le compte n'y est pas je
crois là au risque de vous cevoir
l'objectif est bel et bien atteint il
est même si on peut le dire un peu
dépassé l'ensemble des groupes l'ont
reconnu en commission 7000 agents
service Fran service exerc près de 2700
espaces du du même nom partout en France
ils sont autant de voix et de visages
pour les services publics au côté
également des agents d'accueil et
d'intervention des services publics
locaux et nationaux 95 % des Français
ont un une Fran service à moins de 20
minutes de chez eux et 99 % d'entre eux
à moins de 30 minutes les résultats sont
là le programme à vocation a encore se
développer avec l'élargissement de son
bouquet de service les démarches ma
prime adapte ma prime renove et le
chèque énergie seront possible au 1er
janvier 2024 vous évoquez
également la formation insuffisante de 5
jours et demi là aussi d'importantes
évolutions sont à constater madame la
députée la formation est passée à 11
jour et demi
de plus les conseillers réalisent tout
au long de l'année des immersions chez
les opérateurs pour nouer des relations
de travail et poursivre leur formation
enfin et ensuite quand vous évoquez les
difficultés des des conseillers Fran
service à résoudre les problèmes des
usagers vous vous inscrivez à nouveau en
faux 9 94 % de taux de satisfaction
8 % des usagers ayant eu recours à
France service le recommande quatre
démarches sur 5 sont entièrement résolu
dès la première visite d'un usager c'est
là le plus important les Français qui
utilisent qu' utilisent plébiscite ce
nouveau service à nouveau je vous invite
à vous rendre dans un espace France
service je vous invite à faire un
déplacement oui un déplacement l'un dans
l'un des trois espaces France service
que compte le 18e arrondissement de
Paris je viendrai avec vous enfin au
sujet de la critique fait sur le forfait
de 30000 € qui serait insuffisant
Stanislas Guerini a obtenu une
augentation du forfait
forfait forfait de 30000 € par par franc
service pardon valable en 2022 passer à
35000 € en 2023 et atteindre à 50000 €
en
2026 je suis là je me permets au passage
de pointer une contradiction c'est assez
contreintuitif de considérer que ces
lieux sont inutile et de demander dans
le même temps à ce qu'on augmente le for
le forfait versé pour conclure
et
oui ça arrive sur une dernière citation
de l'exposé des motifs de votre
proposition de loi ces fermetures de
guichets de préfecture sont
emblématiques à plusieurs égards il y a
un engagement fort du président afin de
rouvrir des sous-préfectures déjà si
nouvelles depuis le début du premier
quinquena enfin j'ajouterai qu'une
quarantaine de sous-préfecture accueille
déjà une franc service bref à nouveau
une contevérité à l'URE où nous réarmons
au contraire les sous-préfectures vous
l'aurez compris madame la rapporteur
votre texte est en décalage avec
l'ambition qui est la notre votre texte
est en décalage avec la réalité et la
manière dont les Français accomplissent
leur démarchees administrativ au final
il conduirait à un retour en arrière et
alourdirait les démarches
administratives pour les usagers comme
pour les agents le gouvernement ne
soutiendront ne soutiendra donc pas ce
texte je vous remercie
ministre nous allons madame la
Présidente Panau rappelle au règlement
au titre de quel article au titre de
l'article 100 merci Madame la la
présidente sur la bonne tenue de nos
débats madame la ministre je vais être
extrêmement breve mais je trouve
extrêmement choquant sur un texte aussi
important qui concerne 20 % de nos
concitoyens avec je le rappelle dans
notre pays 8 millions de personnes qui
souffrent d'électronisme et des gens qui
n'arrivent pas à avoir accès au
servicees public ce qui est l'égalité
des citoyens et citoyennes devant la la
République que vous passiez votre temps
à la tribune à rigoler d'un sujet aussi
sérieux que celui-ci quand ce sont des
gens qui n'accèent pas aux apl au
minimum vieillesse qui n'accède pas aux
allocations familiales ou même au titres
de séjour donc je vous appelle à revenir
au sérieux de la situation de ce que
sera représente dans le pays parce que
ce n'est pas nous qui sommes en décalage
avec la réalité c'est vous à ce moment
lorsque vous rigolez qui êtes en
décalage avec ce qui se passe dans le
pays merci madame la Présidente nous
allons maintenant entamer la discussion
générale avec tout d'abord monsieur
Aurélien saintoule pour 10 minutes pour
groupe la France insoumise
[Applaudissements]
nupes merci
beaucoup merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre madame la rapporteur
collègu il n'y a pas de République sans
service public nos concitoyens le s ils
le savent ils y ont ils y sont tous
tellement attachés à ce service public
nous le répétons si souvent dans cet
hémicycle le service public c'est le
patrimoine de ceux qui n'en ont pas
c'est la concrétisation du principe
d'égalité qui figure dans notre devise
que vous soyez riche ou pauvre jeune ou
vieux en ville ou à la campagne la
République vous garantit des droits
grâce au service public ces droits sont
pour la plupart inconditionnelle vous
avez le droit de vivre d'avoir une
identité d'accéder à l'énergie raison
pour laquelle EDF était et devrait être
un service public vous avez le droit
aussi de vous protéger face au risque de
la vie le chômage la vieillesse les
accidents la maladie l'article 1er de la
Constitution consacre la France comme
une République indivisible laïque
démocratique et sociale j'insiste sur ce
dernier adjectif de social car il ne
s'agit pas simplement de consacrer un
droit formel mais bien d'assurer que les
droits doivent être effectif le service
public c'est précisément la
concrétisation d'un droit nous sommes
égau en droit dit la Déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen mais
qu'est-ce que cela signifie non pas que
nous sommes égaux une fois pour toute à
la naissance mais que nous devons agir
pour être égaux en fait et à minima
égaux devant nos droits n'importe où sur
le territoire les citoyens doivent donc
avoir accès à leur droit c'est-à-dire au
service public et pour cela des
administration sont à la disposition de
nos concitoyennes et concitoyens je dis
sont mais je devrais était car depuis
plusieurs années le service public est
affaibli constamment par les politiques
d'austérité mais aussi par la stratégie
de dématérialisation adoptée par les
gouvernements successifs cette stratégie
a bien sûr une part de légitimité on
règle bien des problème par Internet
sans avoir à se déplacer devant un
guichet personne dans cet hémicycle je
le répète personne dans cet hémicycle ne
contestera l'utilité des services
publics en ligne en revanche la
dématérialisation générale is des
services publics laisse de côté un très
grand nombre de personnes j'imagine que
vous avez comme moi à l'esprit la
situation des personnes les plus
vulnérables évidemment c'est d'abord
pour elle que nous défendons cette
proposition de loi de réouverture des
guichets de tous les services publics
lorsque la précarité rend toute démarche
difficile pesante lorsque le quotidien
est incertain et fait peser une charge
mentale qu'en réalité peu d'entre nous
pourrai supporter lorsqu'il faut parer à
l'urgence pour soi pour ses proches ses
enfants alors qu'on n pas internet et
peut-être même pas d'électricité du tout
qu'on vit une situation complexe qui ne
rentre dans aucune case alors on subit
une violence de plus si l'administration
ne nous offre pas de visage humain pas
de voix humaine pour dialoguer je vous
le dis sans misérabilisme en toute
objectivité d'ailleurs il serait faut de
croire que l'absence d'accueil physique
des services publics ne concerne que les
personnes vulnérables les difficultés
qu'elle créent touchent tous les âges
toutes les situations toutes et tous
nous avons ont déjà été littéralement
empêtré dans une procédure dans un
formulaire dont la complexité nous a
paru à vrai dire quasiment surhumaine
combien de fois s'est on dit qu'une
conversation avec un véritable être
humain à l'autre bout du fil aurait
réglé toutes les difficultés dont on
avait cru ne jamais pouvoir sortir ou
encore combien de fois a-t-on laissé
filer en se disant après tout nous ne
vivons pas dans une telle urgence que
nous ne pouvions renoncer à utiliser nos
droits au lieu de nous compliquer la vie
mais les plus jeunes souvent vivent ces
situations et RAR sont ceux qui
pourraient eux se permettre de laisser
filer bien sûr il y a aussi les
personnes les plus âgées nous en avons
toutes et tous dans nos familles qui le
temps passant se sentent moins à l'aise
ou peut-être n'ont jamais été à l'aise
avec l'outil informatique et croyez bien
que non seulement ce qu'on appelle les
digital natives dont on dit qu'ils sont
nés avec une souris greffée au bout des
doigts ne sont pas épargnés par
l'électronisme mais que ceux d'entre eux
qui aujourd'hui parviennent à utiliser
les services en ligne demain et
après-demain auront vieilli et
connaîtront la même difficulté pour
accéder au services publics et faire
valoir leurs droits la dématérialisation
des services publics porte préjudice aux
usagers mais elle nuit aussi
considérablement au travail des agents à
première vue il devait bénéficier de
cette transformation les procédures
allaient être simplifier alléger le
temps consacré à chaque situation
diminué en réalité il n'en est rien non
seulement la dématérialisation a servi
de prétexte à la réduction du nombre
d'agents qui se sont donc retrouvés
surchargés de travail mais en plus le
changement de procédure a fait
apparaître de nouvelles tâches de
gestion qui n'existaient pas auparavant
dites-vous bien qu'à pô emploi
aujourd'hui un agent à la responsabilité
de 1000 dossiers et que s'il doit être
absent pour maladie ou congé personne ne
s'occupera de ces dossiers dans ces
conditions évidemment personne ne peut
soutenir la cadence et nous sommes pris
dans le cercle vicieux dont certains
s'accommodent j'imagine la surcharge de
travail nourrit la peignurie de
personnel la peignurie de personnel
nourrit la surcharge de travail et en
fin de compte les usagers pâtissent et
sont privés de leurs droits être privé
de ces droits c'est non seulement inique
par définition mais c'est proprement
dangereux laisser des personnes privées
de leurs droits c'est laisser la société
entière se dissoudre on parle souvent du
non recours au droit on en connaît les
cause la méconnaissance des procédures
la honte de devoir demander et la peur
de se voir refuser mais ce dont il est
question est contre quoi nous vous
proposons de lutter ce sont des
situations de non recours forcé
avez-vous par exemple déjà essayé de
demander un rendez-vous sous-préfecture
pour tomber sur un message automatique
qui indique aucun créneau n'est
disponible ou pire ce lien a été
désactivé définitivement c'est courant
dans mon propre département des Hautes
scènes savez-vous ce que cela fait
lorsque vous êtes tenu par des délais
d'expiration de vos droits de se dire
qu'un algorithme tranche dans votre vie
que demain vous devrez passer dans
l'illégalité pour avoir un revenu
nourrir vos enfants payer votre loyer
qu'il faudra vous cacher quand vous
verrez un policier non pas parce que
vous êtes en tort mais parce que
l'administration vous a rejeté le
désarroi et la peur qui naissent de ces
situations minent toute la société de
fait je vous parle d'un mal invisible et
qui ronge le pays selon les mots de la
simade les fils d'attente physique ont
été remplacés par des fils d'attente
invisibles mais réel pouvant durer des
mois voir plus d'un an pour l'obtention
d'un simple rendez-vous en préfecture à
cette crise globale le gouvernement
prétend apporter une réponse avec France
service mais ce serait naïveté de notre
part de croire que ces dispositifs
apporteront une solution complète
d'abord France service ne représente pas
un service public homogène sur le
territoire il s'agit d'une
sous-traitance déguisée du service
public certaines maisons sont pilotées
par des associations d'autres par des
collectivités ou encore par des sociétés
comme la poost qui a été privatisé
certains employés des maisons France
service ont certes le statut d'agent de
la fonction publique mais ils sont le
plus souvent salariés de droits privé on
organise la rupture d'égalité entre les
agents comme on acte le renoncement à
servir le public à égalité c'est une
forme de concurrence des entre une
instance qui n'est pas vraiment publique
et des organismes pleinement publics
ensuite le financement lui-même n'est
pas garanti c'est une façon de se
décharger pour l'état d'une partie du
financement sur les collectivités
j'ajoute enfin que la numérisation des
services a pour conséquence de produire
un très grand nombre de données dont le
caractère sensible n'échappe évidemment
à personne et en effet on le sait
désormais le tout numérique permet à
différents organismes d'exploiter ces
données et qui et et ces organismes se
livrent souvent à une surveillance
systématique des plus précaires elles
utilisent par un exemple un algorithme
de notation des allocataires visant à
prédire lesquels ne seraient pas dignees
de confiance et devrait être contrôlé
évidemment c'est une rupture d'égalité
entre les citoyens elle est inadmissible
et la transparence sur les algorithmes
est un préalable à la poursuite de toute
politique de
dématérialisation par cette proposition
nous avons la possibilité d'agir
concrètement sur la vie quotidienne les
Français le savent ils sont plus de 90 à
valider le pour à valid ID le principe
de ce texte nous proposons de revenir au
fondement même de la République sociale
garantir un accueil physique obligatoire
pour tous les service public nous ne
prétendons pas être originaux ni à
forceorie révolutionnaire nous
inscrivons nos pas dans ceux du Conseil
d'État et de la Défenseur des droits le
premier déclare qu'une solution de
substitution effective et crédible doit
toujours être mise en place en plus de
l'usage des téléservices je le répète en
plus de l'usage des téléservices la
deuxième affirme que le seul moyen de
respecter les droits des usagers est de
garantir je cite un principe de double
entrée dans les services publics
évidemment dit en termees plus simples
rien ne pourra remplacer l'existence
d'accueil physique dans les services
publics alors oui certes 80 % bant
malant 80 % des usagers s'en sortent
mais les services publics sont là pour
tous nous ne pouvons pas expulser de la
citoyenneté ou de la société 20 % de la
population c'est inconcevable et c'est
inacceptable si vous nous donnez acte de
cette affirmation et de ce raisonnement
vous devez donc voter cette proposition
de
loi merci monsieur le
député la parole est à Monsieur Raphaël
chéon berger pour les républicains et
pour 5
minutes merci madame la présidente
madame la secrétaire d'État madame la
rapporteur chers collègues ce texte est
un texte qui réaffirme un principe en
cela il est noble que notre assemblée
puisse en débattre et Madame la Ministre
parler d'accueil physique en vous
attendant une demi-heure ça n'est pas
forcément agréable pour la
représentation nationale devant laquelle
vous êtes responsable cela étant dit
j'aimerais d'abord rappeler que nous
considérons avec les républicains que le
numérique est d'abord un atout pour le
service public public le numérique a
permis une amélioration de l'efficacité
du service rendu au français en créant
notamment une logique de d'accès en
permanence pour une bonne partie de nos
concitoyens et si nous devons débattre
de l'accueil physique cela ne doit pas
se faire en opposition de l'accueil
numérique qui est une vraie amélioration
de la qualité d'accueil pour bon nombre
de nos concitoyens qui peuvent faire au
cours de la journée oou qu'il soit ou de
la nuit leur démarche administrative
c'est donc donc une bonne chose mais un
certain nombre de coeffets ont été
générés par la mise en place de ces
services numériques parfois même sur
notre propre façon de construire les
politiques publiques la quantité de
données que nous collectons la finesse
des analyses que nous pouvons faire
grâce au numérique nous conduisent
parfois y compris nous législateurs y
compris depuis les bans qui proposent
cette ce texte aujourd'hui à construire
des dispositifs qui s'éloignent un peu
trop des principes et qui rentrent trop
dans le détail et et qui cherche
systématiquement l'exception ce sont des
choses qui sont nées du numérique et de
la quantité colossale du donné que de
données que que produit le le
numérique parfois un certain nombre de
choses nous manquent aussi avec la
numérisation de l'accueil et je prends
l'exemple d'un débat qui est souvent
venu et et et d'un sujet que nous
portons avec les républicains qui est le
rétablissement pour les mairres du
fichier domiciliaire c'est un débat qui
si le lien physique entre les
administrés d'une commune et leur
administration était plus régulier
n'aurait sûrement pas lieu mais
l'effacement de la rencontre entre
l'institution communal et les
concitoyens nécessit parfois qu'on
apporte des réponses structurelles
techniques qui viennent compenser ces
manques de de
rencontres réaffirmer enfin que le
numérique est une compétence en tant que
tel une compétence qu'il a fallu
acquérir très vite pour nombre de nos
compatriotes c'est une technologie qui a
pénétré nos
quotidiens sans réellement qu'on prenne
le temps d'apprendre à l'utiliser et
aujourd'hui c'est
incontournable d'ailleurs c'est pas
toujours les publics que l'on croit on
pense souvent qu'il y a une faracture au
au niveau de l'âge je ne crois pas que
la fracture en matière de compréhension
de maîtrise de l'outil numérique soit
une fracture de génération bien au
contraire elle est beaucoup plus
complexe que cela et face à la vitesse à
laquelle cet outil c'est à pénétrer nos
quotidiens nous n'avons pas eu de
stratégie d'alphabétisation disons-le de
cette façon-là transposons ce mot
alphabétisation en terme numérique
j'aime bien ce mot parce que c'est un
mot qui décrit cette volonté de l'action
publique d'aller vert pour construire
ensemble la compréhension du moyen du de
communication qui nous lit la preuve
aujourd'hui c'est que nous mettons bon
nombre de moyens l'État les
collectivités territoriales sur la table
pour lutter contre la diffusion trop
rapide d'informations inexactes voire
manipulé que nous créons des politiques
de lutte contre
l'ilectronisme comme si nous avions un
manque à combler c'est bien que nous
n'avons sûrement pas au préalable fait
le travail de d'éducation a de
compréhension de ce qu'est l'outil
numérique
euh enfin dernier élément la question de
l'accessibilité du service public et et
cela plaide dans le sens de cette
proposition de loi euh n'est pas qu'une
question de temporalité de guichet mais
aussi une question d'accompagnement et
force de constater que nombre de nos
dispositifs sont particulièrement
complexes et que nous avons une fâcheuse
tendance à à pondre des dispositifs de
plus en plus complexes et cela nécessite
donc nécessairement de la médiation et
rien de plus efficace que qu'un qu'un
homme qu'une femme pour accompagner nos
concitoyens dans la compréhension voilà
maises mes chers collègues je ne
seruraai que vous appelez à à faire
preuve d'humilité face à à ce défi à
faire preuve d'humanité face au
traitement en nombre que qu'impose le
numérique et je ne crois pas qu'il y ait
de vérité à critiquer un moyen ou
l'autre nous avons une nécessité de
construire la rencontre entre l'accueil
physique et l'accueil numérique merci
monsieur le député la parole est à
Madame Mathilde desjanquer pour le
groupe démocrate et pour 5
minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci
bonsoir madame la présidente madame la
ministre madame la rapporteur mes chers
collègues ces 10 dernières années la
transformation numérique des services
publique s'est accélérée en France pour
s'imposer comme une nouvelle norme du
service public au centre de la
modernisation de l'État cette transition
numérique s'inscrit dans une logique de
de modernisation d'efficacité et de
simplicité des services publics dans
notre société de l'immédiateté la
dématérialisation des services publics
permet de pouvoir faire ses démarches
administrativ et d'avoir accès aux
informations au jour et à l'heure que
l'on souhaite ce souci de la rapidité
répond aux attentes légitimes de nos
concitoyens en effet même si le mode
d'accès privilégié reste le guicher pour
effectuer les formalités administratives
la proportion d'usagers utilisant
Internet augmente chaque année 83 % des
Français en 2014 92 % en 2022 soit une
augmentation de 9 points l'objectif de
cette évolution technologique est
également de renforcer la sécurité et
d'apporter des services plus avancés
pour cela la question de la couverture
numérique est capitale notamment dans
les territoires ruraux comme j'ai pu le
souligner dans le rapport d'évaluation
des services publics en ruralité que
j'ai rendu début avril avec notre
collègue Pierre Morel à luisser le plan
France très haut débit a
incontestablement permis d'accélérer cet
état de fait même si nous pouvons y
apporter la nuance de la finalisation
encore en cours si le basculement vers
le numérique peut représenter une
simplification des démarches
administratives et une amélioration du
service pour une partie des usagers et
des usagères la dématérialisation peut
accentuer la fracture numérique et
laisser deux côtés les plus précaires
pour ces situation la présence physique
des services est indispensable c'est
donc dans cette logique que le Président
de la République avait annoncé en avril
2019 la création des maisons France
servic dans chaque canton d'ici la fin
de son quinquena soit environ 2000
structures sur l'ensemble du territoire
national au premier février 2021 plus de
1123 maisons France service ont sont
ouvertes l'objectif de ces maisons et de
rapprocher les services publics au plus
près des concitoyens en particulier dans
les zones rurales et les quartiers
prioritaires mais aussi d'accompagner
ces personnes en difficultés dans leur
démarche en ligne et de les former à
l'utilisation d'outils numériques le
dispositif de cette proposition de loi
qui prévoit de réinstaurer l'obligation
de proposer un accès physique au
servicees public est donc déjà satisfait
il est également important d'insister
sur le point le point suivant Infiné la
dématérialisation ne remplace pas
l'humain elle réoriente la mission des
agents elle réoriente les lignes
budgétaires derrière internet il y a
forcément de fait la main de l'homme
réduire la dématérialisation à la case
du service public comme il est fait dans
ce texte est un l'URE aujourd'hui chaque
usager a la possibilité de choisir
l'accès qui lui convient le mieux sans
qu'il soit déboussolé cette proposition
de loi ne serait donc pas facilitatrice
dans la vie des Français et des
Françaises la facilité c'est garantir
une adaptabilité pour une égalité de
tout un chacun tel que le prévoit
l'accès au service public il est à noter
que d'ici décembre 2023 plus de 2700
maisons France service seront ouvertes
sur tout le territoire de ce fait le
dispositif proposé est déjà satisfait
évoquer son amélioration son
développement est autre chose le comité
d'évaluation et de contrôle et les
rapports qui en sont produit par exemple
comme celui dont je vous ai parlé tout à
l'heure nous permettent justement
d'envisager ces évolutions comme je l'ai
rappelé également en commission des lois
le renoncement au numérique
constituerait un net retour en arrière
pour la grande majorité des Français qui
privilégiaent le canal numérique pour
faire leur démarche administrative
retour en arrière privilégion plutôt une
vision généreuse ambitieuse et optimiste
pour nos concitoyens pour toutes les
raisons que je viens d'évoquer le groupe
démocrate ne votera pas ce texte je vous
remercie merci madame la députée la
parole est à Monsieur Michel Boulou pour
le groupe socialiste et apparenté pour 5
minutes c'est
bon madame la présidente madame la
ministre madame la rapporteur chers
collègues face à la dématalisation des
services publics et la rupture d'accès
au droits que ce phénomène induit
notamment pour les personnes âgées mais
également pour celles qui sont en
situation de précarité la proposition de
loi qui occupe nos débats aujourd'hui
entend mettre à la charge de
l'administration la réouverture des
accueils physiques dans nos services
publics car le constat est sans appel à
la dématérialisation généralisée nombre
de nos concitoyens subissent un
sentiment d'abandon nourri par une
fracture numérique certes la
dématérialisation constitue a de
nombreux avantages je l'utilise là en ce
moment en tout cas sur le plan théorique
sur la rapidité en particulier des
traitements des dossiers administratifs
sur le plan théorique car c'est encore
loin d'être le cas quand on songe aux
délais qui se sont considérablement
allongés on l'a vu vous l'avez tous eu
dans vos permanence pour la délivrance
de carte nationale d'identité de
passeports nationaux ou
internationaux cela dit ce n'est pas
tant la dématérialisation des démarches
administratives qui posent problème nous
devons suivre le train de la
modernisation mais plutôt la fermeture
des guichets de proximité et le fait que
de nombreuses personnes restent sur le
quai ainsi la France n'a pas encore
résolu la ouverture numérique de tout le
territoire ce qui de facto entraîne des
inégalités d'accès à Internet en
particulier dans les zones rurales selon
un rapport de l'INC de 2022 quelques 7,5
% des ménages français n'ont pas accès à
Internet et la France est seulement en
14e position à l'échelle de l'Europe et
présente d'importantes lacunes sur le
plan de la couverture numérique entre
les zones blanches où il n'y a aucun
opérateur les zones grises desservi par
un seul opérateur ou les zones d'ombre
où la connexion est de très mauvaise
qualité par ailleurs l'électronisme
c'est-à-dire le fait de ne pas avoir les
compétences de base ou de ne pas savoir
se servir d'Internet touche 15,4 % des
plus de 15 ans sont touchés plus
particulièrement les seniors les plus
les personnes les plus modestes celles
qui ont qu'ils sont le moins diplômés
les personnes vivant seul ou parfois les
habitants d'aoutre mè si ces deux
éléments le problème de la couverture
numérique et l'éleectronisme ne sont pas
pris en compte la pardon excusez-moi la
dématérialisation devient un outil de
destruc
des services publics dans son rapport
d'activité pour 2021 la Défenseur des
droits clair et Don dresse un bilan
particulièrement critique de la
politique menée depuis quelques années
en faveur d'une accélération de la
dématérialisation de nos services
publics je la cite souvent pensé par le
prisme de l'optimisation de l'efficience
ou de la simplification les politiques
de modernisation ou de transformation
publique ont inconcessablement eu des
effets sur l'accès au droits de toutes
et tous dont le Défenseur des droits est
un témoin direct
dès 2019 le prédécesseur de Madame Édon
Jacques Toubon écornait également
vertement le tout numérique dans nos
services publics il disait il ne peut y
avoir de discrimination fondée sur le
lieu de résidence du point de vue de
l'égalité de la solidarité et de l'accès
au droit c'est inacceptable en somme il
importe que nos services publics
s'inspirent de l'esprit qui préside
outre atlantique chez nos habis
québécois où on ne parle pas de service
public mais de service au public notre
pays doit repersonnaliser urgemment
notre administration publique tout le
monde aurait à y gagner d'une part les
usagers qui se sentiraient mieux
accompagnés et d'autre part les agents
qui sont en perte de sens dans des
tâches qu'ils accomplissent et qui
surtout les tiennent à distance de tout
contact humain chacun ici l'aura compris
sur le sujet que nos collègues du groupe
de la France insoumise portent
aujourd'hui et qui consiste à remettre
l'humain dans nos services publics le
groupe des socialistes et apparenté
apportera évidemment son soutien nous
rappelons au passage que notre groupe
propose chaque année dans le cadre du
PLF malheureusement il y a des 493 à
chaque fois des amendements qui visent à
renforcer les effectifs dans les
préfectures afin d'assurer cet accueil
physique auquel ont droit les usagers
des services publics la situation dans
les préfectures y est en effet alarmante
si on s'y réfère encore une fois au
dernier rapport de la Cour des comptes
en somme nous voterons pour ce texte
merci Madame la Ministre madame la
rapporteur chers collègues le texte
réouverture des accueils physiques dans
les services publics proposé aujourd'hui
met l'accent sur la problématique de
l'accès de nos concitoyens au servicees
publics tous les Français doivent
évidemment pouvoir accéder au services
public et l'État se doit d'offrir un
accès simple qualitatif et adapté à tous
les citoyens quel que soit leur milieu
social quel que soit leur âge et qu'ils
vivent en milieu urbain ou en milieu
rural depuis près de 20 ans nous
constatons un profond changement des
rapports des usagers à à
l'administration comme le souligne le
Conseil d'État nous sommes passés d'une
approche uniforme des administrés à des
bénéficiaires de politique publique dont
la diversité et l'hétérogénéité n'ont
cessé de croître afin de répondre au
mieux à cette individualisation des
situations et donc pour simplifier et
faciliter ses rapports avec les
administrés l'État s'est engagé dans une
profonde transformation à l'aair du
numérique la la dématérialisation a is
d'accélérer et de simplifier les
démarches administratives et il est
indispensable de reconnaître la
disponibilité élargi des services et la
réduction des délais d'instruction de
certains dossiers
administratifs pour ne prendre qu'un
seul exemple personne ne nira l'immense
avancée que constitue le prélèvement à
la
source cette numérisation cette
dématérialisation n'ont-elles eu que des
effets
positifs la réponse a été évidemment non
mais l'exposé des motifs de cette
proposition de loi dépint un constat
quelque peu
trompeur oui il faut reconnaître que
sous l'effet de cette numérisation
l'administration s'est éloignée de
certains usagers tous les usagers non 80
% des citoyens n'ont de n'ont pas de
difficulté pour accéder à
l'administration notamment grâce à cette
numérisation et pour rapprocher les
services publics et les citoyens les
plus éloigné du numérique des mesures
ont été prises première mesure dans le
cadre de France relance 908 millions
d'euros ont été prévus pour accélérer la
transformation numérique dont 250
millions dédiés à l'inclusion
numérique deuxème mesure la direction
interministérielle du numérique a été
créée pour développer les dispositifs de
dématérialisation pour promouvoir un
design plus inclusif et pour améliorer
la qualité de l'ensemble des services
publics
numériques trème mesure des services des
espaces France France service ont ouvert
partout sur le territoire français nous
sommes passés de 460 structures en 2020
à 2561 structure en 2023 dont certaines
sont mobiles en voulant imposer une
présence physique pour chaque service
public la présente proposition de loi ne
prend pas en compte l'évolution des
besoins des usagers compte tenu de la
diversité des publics et des situations
le groupe horizon et apparenté est
convaincu que plusieurs options doivent
être proposées aux usagers une solution
numérique et une possibilité
d'assistance physique ou téléphonique
comme le recommande le Conseil d'État
nous soutiendrons toutes les solutions
qui visent à offrir le plus grand panel
possible aux usagers or aujourd'hui le
groupe LFI nous propose un traitement
indifférencié de toutes les situations
le groupe horizon et apparenté ne va
donc pas en faveur de cette proposition
de loi je vous
remercie merci Madame
Gérard la parole est à Madame Marie
pochon pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
écologiste merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
ce vendredi alors que je me rendais à un
rendez-vous à la communauté de commune
de diulfi Bourdeau dans la Drom je suis
passée au premier ét devant un bureau
fermé celui du centre des impôts depuis
quelques mois les habitants du
centrebourg de dilefille doivent faire
40 minutes de voiture ou 1 heure pour se
rendre dans au centre des impôts à
Valence et je ne parle pas de ceux des
20 villages alentour les services
publics sont ce qui nous est commun ils
sont notre protection collective et
inconditionnelle ils sont en matière de
mobilité de logement d'alimentation
d'éducation de soins d'émancipation la
garantie de l'accès aux droits et aux
libertés pour toutes et tous de
l'égalité de ceci l'expression la plus
concrète de la solidarité et de la
fraternité nationale ils sont
l'espérance d'une vie meilleure oui
chers collègues les services publics
sont le fondement même de la promesse
républicaine séparer la République des
idées de justice sociale serait n'en
faire qu'un mot disait joures
aujourd'hui les logiques d'accumulation
et de prédation des ressources nous
mènent droit au mur et laissent grandir
tant d'inégalités tant de pauvreté sans
que jamais les mécanismes de marché que
certains ici aiment temp ne viennent
réparer les dégâts c'est ce que font les
services publics il répare il protège il
créent les conditions du vivre ensemble
quand ils sont accessibles pour tous et
partout leur présence est tout
simplement ce qui fait qu'à montbrin les
Bains comme dans le 7e arrondissement de
Paris on se sait avoir la même valeur on
se sait être considéré de la même
manière par la République le problème
c'est que ça marche pas tout à fait
comme ça d'abord loin des utopies de la
République sociale cher ajouress
l'austérité gronde dans les territoires
ruraux ce sont les départs des bureaux
de poste et des centres des impôts qui
doucement se font remplacer par des
agences Fran service tenu souvent à bout
de bras par des acteurs associ
associatifs et des élus locaux ce sont
les classes qui ferment les médecins qui
manquent qui fait que dans nos villages
on vit 2 ans de moins en moyenne que
dans les grandes villes ce sont chers
collègues des déplacements que l'on ne
fait plus la faute à un carburant hors
de prix et à des offres de transport
alternatif inadéquate le nombre d'agents
s'effondre peu à peu le numérique vient
tout remplacer une révolution qui
devrait apporter la possibilité pour
chacun depuis chez soi d'accéder à
Internet et à des services
administratifs au processus simplifi le
gouvernement projette d'atteindre d'ici
2025 la dématérialisation de 100 % des
démarches d'accès au services
publics le bilan de cette trèsclinquante
startup nation n'est pas bien glorieux
et si cette simplification numérique
devrait le permettre il peinene à le
garantir un français sur de de plus de
60 ans est en situation d'éectronisme 8
% des Français n'ont pas d'adresse mail
15 % ne dispose pas de connexion
Internet de même 70 % des ménages et de
montagne n'ont même pas la fibre avec la
dématérialisation il y a les connectés
qui ont accès à leurs droits et les
autres oubliés invisibles on construit
une France à deux vitesses c'estes
oubliés ces invisibles on en reçoit tant
dans nos permanences madame la ministre
parce qu'ils sont perdus avec vos apps
et vos connexions à 15 facteurs parce
que personne ne leur répond au bout du
fil que vous nous donnerez sans doute un
label Fran service dans quelques temps
et ce ne sont pas les seuls manquements
de la transformation numérique du
service public je m'inquiète par exemple
du transfert de la responsabilité de la
réussite ou de l'échec d'une démarche de
l'administration à l'usager s'il n'est
pas assez bien équipé s'il ne comprend
pas tout ce qui lui est demandé ou tout
simplement qu'il se trompe l'usager
pourrait se voir imputer l'erreur et se
voir sanctionner double peine donc car
il serait sanctionné de ne pas avoir
compris de ne pas avoir accès au droits
qu'il demandait voire d'être considéré
comme un fraudeur je m'inquiète de la
charge de travail et de la perte de sens
pour les agents dans leur métiers
pourtant si essentiel pour le bien
commun dans son enquête auprès de 3000
agents le collectif nos services publics
estimer que 80 % d'entre eux ressentent
un sentiment d'absurdité dans leur
travail dans leur témoignage certains
rapportent que la transformation
numérique se fait à moyen constant et
sans formation d'autres regrettent des
outils numériques qui ne conviennent pas
aux usages de terrain chers collègues
face à l'explosion des inégalités le
demi-million de Françaises et de
Français qui ont basculé dans la
pauvreté en 2021 face à la fracture
territoriale qui abîme la croyance en un
idéal républicain qui s'applique à
toutes et tous de la même manière
oui notre responsabilité doit être de
construire plutôt que de détruire
d'assurer la présence humaine plutôt que
son absence celle de plus de services
publics physiques de plus de promesses
républicaines où que l'on vive et quel
que soit notre âge quels que soient les
outils numériques que l'on possède c'est
l'exigence posée par la Défenseur des
droits que l'usager puisse avoir le
choix du mode d'administration qui lui
correspond le mieux c'est l'exigence
posée par le Conseil d'État lui-même qui
demande la mise en place d'alternative
au services en ligne pour l'ensemble des
démarches administratives d'accès au
services public ce doit être notre
exigence aussi le groupe écologiste
vtera bien évidemment pour cette
proposition de loi je vous remercie
merci Madame
pochon la parole est à Monsieur David
riman pour le groupe de la Gauche
démocrate et
républicaine bonsoir ça
va
madame la présidente Madame la madame la
rapporteur madame la ministre bonsoir
chers collègues il est très facile de
partir du constat que la
dématérialisation des démarches
administratives permettrait de
simplifier l'accès au service public et
que ce serait en plus un gain de temps
pour nous usagers c'est oublié que la
dématérialisation doit avant tout être
un moyen et non une fin et donc que
l'accompagnement à la dématérialisation
aurait en fait dû précéder la mise en
place de celle-ci c'est donc faire
preuve d'une certaine fénéantise
intellectuelle voire d'un certain
élitisme ou tout simplement de naïveté
que de croire que nous sommes tous égaux
face à nos
écrans les rapports sur l'électronise
sur le non recours sur le manque
d'information sur le manque de culture
digitale et j'ens passe ne manque pas
mais nous continuons d'année en année à
pratiquer la politique bien commode de
l'autruche à remplacer des gens par des
bornes à creuser les inégalités à isoler
toute une partie de la population non
seulement les personnes précaires mais
aussi les alophones les personnes en
situation de handicap les personnes
âgées les étrangers et cetera et cetera
et cetera les exclus du numérique sont
nombreux et la liste s'allonge au même
rythme que nos démarches administratives
se dématérialisent et que le numérique
conquier de nouveaux domaines il suffit
de consulter le rapport sur le sujet de
l'ancien défenseur des droits Jacques
touban publié en 2019 pour prendre la
mesure de la rupture qui se crée au sein
même de la population nul besoin de
rappeler qu'en matière de rupture
d'égalité de société à deux voir trois
vitesses les territoires ultramarins
sont bien souvent des cas d'école en
autre mare tout particulièrement
l'électronisme est prignant un rapport
sénatorial de 2020 rappelle qu'il
concerne près de 30 % de la population
hors Mayotte contre moins de 20 % en
hexagone à cela il faut ajouter un accès
à Internet complètement instable des
équipements matériel qui sont d'une
dorée rare et qui sont donc extrêmement
chers et surtout j'aimerais insister
là-dessus la la barrière de la longue
qui décourage toute une partie de la
population de continuer à se rendre dans
des rares lieux d'accueil du public qui
existe et encore faudrait-il que ces
personnes aient les moyens de s'y rendre
car je rappelle que le territoire
guyanais par exemple est la plus vaste
région de France qui est couvert à 96 %
par la forêt équatoriale et que les
2/ers du territoire sont inaccessibles
par voix terrestre et que donc les
habitants sont obligés de faire des
longs trajets pour accéder à des
services publics le cise l'a très bien
résumé dans un rapport de 2020 l'offre
de service public doit être adapté aux
difficultés socio-économiques
rencontrées par la population aux
évolution démographique ainsi qu'à ses
caractéristiques culturelles et
linguistiques déjà en 2018 la CNCDH
notait que la barrière de la langue
constitue un frein important à la
connaissance du droit et à l'orientation
dans les services publics nous ne sommes
pas réfractaires à la dématérialisation
mais nous sommes mais nous réaffirmons
notre attachement à la pluralité des
modalités de prise de contact avec les
administration
nous voterons bien sûr pour ce texte
mais raffirmons notre souhait que les
langues majoritaires dans les
territoires ultramarin puissent être
davantage prise en considération dans
cette prise de contact face au numérique
la République est multiple je vous
remercie merci Monsieur
ran la parole est à Monsieur Michel
Castellani pour le groupe liberté
indépendant outreem et
territoireir ça
va madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur madame la ministre mes chers
collègues nos concitoyens alertent de
plus en plus sur la disparition des
services publics et sur le recul de
l'État en particulier dans les
territoires ruraux insulaires et
ultramarin le risque d'une rupture du
lien entre usagers et administration
territoriale reste présent en dépit des
annonces du gouvernement deppis aussi
des moyens déployés en réaction cette
PPL pose le principe d'un retour à la
logique de guichet physique et
d'accompagnement en présentiel du public
et notre groupe lot souscrit pleinement
à cet objectif certes pour une majorité
d'usagers des services publics la
dématérialisation est une avancée
néanmoins cette transformation numérique
ne doit pas se faire à marche forcé sans
tenir compte des difficultés bien
réelles que rencontre une partie de la
population la réalité est que depuis le
début des années 2000 aux fractures
sociales et territoriales s'ajoute une
nouvelle fracture
numérique 15 % des Français sont en
situation d'électronisme n'ont pas la
capacité d'utiliser les dispositifs
numériques et d'effectuer des démarches
en ligne en ce sens cette PPL en
prévoyant un accompagnement en plus d'un
accueil physique à chaque étape
administrative apporte une solution
concrète aux US AG dans ce rapport de
2023 l'usager du 1er au dernier
kilomètre le Conseil d'État part du
constat d'un faossé qui s'est creusé
entre usagers et action publique il
rappelle que certaines transformations
si elles sont bénéfiques pour la
majorité des usagers non ont des
conséquences négatives pour certains
publics la situation laisse à la fois
les publics fragiles en particulier bien
sûr les usagers âgés ou en situation de
précarité et les publics des territoires
ruraux insulaair et ultramarins qui sont
déjà éloignés des administrations je
veux parler comme exemple de la corseî
montagne qui cumule de nombreuses
difficultés liées mais pas seulement à
la géographie sur ce territoire comment
d'autres et contrairement aux idées
reçues la fracture numérique ne concerne
pas que les personnes âgées mais aussi
de nombreux actifs et une part non
négligeable des jeunes il faut également
composer avec les difficultés inhérentes
au relief à titre d'exemple dans le C
Corse qui est le mien euh qui est
constitué d'une succession de vallées
profonde la radio le téléphone ou
Internet ne sont pas diffusé
convenablement malgré les efforts
fournis et en conséquence la
numérisation des services et quelquefois
pour Cees territoire carrément synonyme
d'abandon et comment ne pas évoquer
l'éparpillement communal la Corse pour
rester sur cet exemple et parsé de vill
côtière et de villages en hauteur reliés
par des routes sinueuses et les trajets
sont en conséquence long et éprouvant
toute suppression au regroupement de
service public revient à une incitation
supplémentaire à des certification et
moi j'en raelle une fois de plus on
maintient des guichets postaux et des
services publics en Corse comme ailleurs
à ce titre notre groupe reconnaît les
efforts et les moyens déployés ces
dernières années pour mettre fin à
l'éloignement de l'État dans les
territoires la réouverture de certaines
sous-préfectures a été un signal positif
dans le même sens les 2600
France service constitue un réseau
essentiel avec une logique de guichet
unique cependant ces moyens restent
souvent insuffisant dans les zones
rurales et ultramarines et au-delà du
périmètre de préfecture c'est l'ensemble
des différents services publics
nationaux de l'État ou de la sécurité
sociale qui a reculé ou disparu sans
nier l'utilité des téléprocédures et
téléservices bien sûr notre groupe
estime que cette numérisation se fait
faute de moyens dans des conditions
contraires à la tradicction du service
public ces derniers reposent sur trois
piliers la continuité l'égalité et la
mutabilité force de constater qu'une
simple téléprocédure sans dispositif de
substitution pour s'adapter aux besoins
des usagers et des territoires n'est pas
à la hauteur de ces principes notre
groupe s'inquiète également d'une
déresponsabilisation de notre
administration l'état territorial a
tendance à se décharger sur d'autres
acteurs en particulier les collectivités
et le secteur association nous sommes
donc pleinement favorables à l'article
1er de cette PPL sans revenir sur la
montée en puissance du téléservice il
obligera l'administration à maintenir un
site d'accueil physique afin de recevoir
les usagers qui en feront la demande
cela permettra par la même occasion de
maintenir un lien et d'apporter un
accompagnement à chaque étape de toute
démarche administrative je vous
remerci merci Monsieur
Castellani la parole est à Monsieur
gouffierent pour groupe
[Applaudissements]
Renaissance madame la
présidente madame la ministre madame la
rapporteur mes chers collègues nous
examinons à présent la proposition de
loi tendant à la réouverture des
accueils physiques dans les services
publics déposés par la France insoumise
dans le cadre de cette journée
parlementaire l'intensité des débats que
nous avons eu en commission des lois
témoigne de l'importance du sujet en
effet la numérisation des services
publics touche directement nos
concitoyennes et concitoyens et l'accès
au droits est une thématique majeure de
notre société pilier de notre République
sociale comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le
souligné en commission nous rejoignons
le constat de la rapporteur sur
l'importance de maintenir plusieurs
modalités d'accès au services publics
mais si nous avons rejeté cette
proposition de loi en commission nous
maintenons notre position dubitative en
séance puisque c'est justement le cap
que nous tenons depuis 2017 nous
n'opposons pas numérique et physique
mais envisageons le premier comme un
moyen de simplification complémentaire
du second en ce sens les propos tenu en
commission qui futtigait la
dématérialisation des services publics
parce qu'elle dégraderait la relation à
l'usager insuffle l'idée d'un certain
c'était mieux avant et je tiens à saluer
l'intervention exemplaire de notre
collègue Marie agè pousier vinsbach du
groupe horizon en commission et regrette
quand même le mythe d'un certain âge
d'or fantasmé qui guide aujourd'hui la
position de certaines et certains de nos
collègues c'était mieux avant mais au
fond de quoi parle-t-on non ce n'était
pas mieux avant le numérique permet une
modernisation de l'État et de nos
services publics une grande majorité de
nos concitoyennes et concitoyens qui ont
une pratique volontaire du numérique
voit leur démarche administrative
simplifié la dématérialisation renforce
leur autonomie l'accès numérisé à
certains services publics est facilité
en témoigne l'utilisation massive de
France Connect je pourrais aussi citer
le dispositif dites-le nous une fois qui
facilite la circulation des données
entre les administrations pour éviter
aux usagers de fournir une 1ème fois des
informations qu'ils ont déjà donné mais
vous semblez vous opposer à cette
simplification des usages puisque votre
groupe a voté contre la loi 3DS l'année
dernière qui visait justement et bien a
développer ce dispositif ce texte
représente un retour en arrière pour la
grande majorité de nos concitoyens qui
privilégient le calin numérique et
s'affranchissent ainsi de contraintes
horair inhérentes au guichet physique
non ce n'était pas mieux avant le
numérique permet de garantir
l'effectivité des droits et limite le
non recours ou pour citer l'étude
annuelle du Conseil d'État sur le
dernier kilomètre de l'action publique
le recours au numérique présente un
immense potentiel de développement pour
limiter le non recours au droits
notamment c'est tout le sens de la
solidarité à la source qui prévoit le
versement automatique des prestations
sociales loin de la remplacer le
numérique appuie l'administration pour
ne laisser aucun de nos concitoyens de
côté en ce sens 60 millions d'euros ont
été investis pour rendre les 250 sites
de démarchees administrativ les plus
utilisés accessibles au aux personnes en
situation de handicap et des sanctions
sont prévues pour le non respect des
exigences d'accessibilité alors non ce
n'était pas mieux avant parce qu'avant
il n'y avait qu'un seul canal pour
reindre l'administration aujourd'hui sur
plus de 200 millions de de
sollicitations traité par un agent 43 %
l'ont été par le téléphone 32 % par le
numérique 15 % par le physique et 10 %
par le courrier preuve s'il en est que
votre proposition de loi est largement
satisfaite alors dans quel passé plus ou
moins idéalisés les usagers
bénéficient-il d'un accès multicanal
pour garantir l'effectivité de leur
droits d'une certaine manière les 2543
espace France service représentent en
cela un succès que nous nous
continuerons de développer en
élargissant le bouquet de service
délivrés 99 % des Français sont ainsi à
moins de 30 minutes d'une maison France
service et 93 % des usagers des maisons
sont satisfaits de la qualité des
services les conseillers numériques
France servic ont notamment pour mission
d'aider les usagers vers l'autonomie en
leur donnant les clés pour réaliser leur
démarche via le numérique ces agents
peuvent ainsi se focaliser sur les
situations administratives plus
complexes et subvenir aux besoins de nos
concitoyennes et concitoyens qui en ont
le plus besoin je tiens à remercier ici
d'ailleurs les milliers d'agents
d'agents France service qui accompagnent
chaque jour nos consitoyennes et
concitoyens dans la réalisation de leur
démarche et qui sont les visages de nos
services publics enfin nous continuerons
à déployer la fibre optique sur tout le
territoire grâce au plan France très
haut débit dont nous avons largement
évoqué le sujet en commission des lois
alors non la dématérialisation n'est pas
un cache misère de la destruction de
servicees publics les principes du
service public continuité égalité
adaptabilité sont garanties il ne s'agit
pas d'opposer l'un à l'autre mais de
voir comment nous faisons mieux
fonctionner nos services publics tout en
les modernisant toujours alors pour ces
raisons le groupe Renaissance ne pourra
pas soutenir cette proposition toutefois
madame la rapporteur je vous demanderai
une demande une suspension de séance à
la fin de cette discussion générale afin
que nous évquion peut-être quelques
point de cette proposition de loi si
vous le voulez bien je vous remercie je
vous remercie monsieur Gouffier Valante
et la parole est à Madame Géraldine
Grangier pour le groupe rassemblement
[Applaudissements]
national madame la présidente madame la
ministre madame le rapporteur mes chers
collègues nous sommes réunis aujourd'hui
pour examiner la proposition de loi du
groupe etfi tendant à la réouverture des
des accueils physiques dans les services
publics et bien il s'agit là d'une
priorité qu'au rassemblement national
nous partageons aussi oui il faut
réouvrir les accueils physiques dans les
services publics oui les Français dans
l'ensemble de nos départements pleurent
leurs services public ils en ont assez
de la dématérialisation et des services
vocaux des plateformes téléphoniques oui
ils veulent retrouver légitimement un
accueil physique où ils seront traités
en citoyens ils sont une majorité à être
faorable à la réouverture d'accueil
physique dans les services publics alors
évidemment madame le rapporteur nous
partageons votre constat successivement
les gouvernements précédents ont fermé
tous les guichets de servicees publics
la Poste la gendarmerie les impôts les
points accueil CAF la sécurité sociale
et Messa et cetera ils ont éloigné
toujours un peu plus chacun de nos
compatriotes des administration de la
République pour optimiser les ressources
et obéir surtout à des logiques
comptables ils ont remplacé l'accueil
physique du public au guichet accessible
prochet aident par des alternatives
largement insuffisante allant notamment
de la plateforme téléphonique au site
internet parmi les grands principes du
vrai service public qui sont la
continuité l'égalité et
l'adaptabilité les gouvernants ont
surtout oublié celui
d'égalité ce principe d'égalité mes
chers collègues a pourtant valeur
constitutionnelle il doit dans notre
pays permettre l'égal accès de chacun au
service public sans discrimination ni
avantage ce n'est plus le cas
malheureusement aujourd'hui ce principe
cardinal est largement entamé fragilisé
abîmé nous envoyons les résultats
désastreux et le Défenseur des droits en
témoigne l'accès au droits des usagers
s'effondre on découvre régulièrement
dans les journaux ou à la radio des
situations ubuesques des retraité ne
parvenant pas à bénéficier de leur
retraite des usagers qui ne rentrent pas
dans les cases bref l'objectif de cette
république en déclin n'est plus d'offrir
à tous l'idéal de l'égalité devant
l'accès au servic public mais bien de
proposer à nos compatriotes les plus
fragiles les plus âgés ceux de la
ruralité et des cités un service public
lowcost à Bac coup un service public
amoindri
altéré avec des administrations
régulièrement fermé au public contrainte
de délivrer un service de seconde zone
un service pour des sous citoyens des
citoyens moins importants que d'autres
des citoyens qui peuvent attendre des
citoyens qu'on méprise par l'oubli vous
l'avez compris mes chers collègues c'est
ça qui me révolte et qui doit nous
révolter collectivement c'est pour cela
qu'il faut réouvrir les accueils
physiques dans les service publics il
faut je le crois renouer et retrouver ce
qui fait la grandeur et la qualité du
service public peut-on continuer encore
à banaliser pire à théoriser comme un
progrès l'existence des administrations
qui ne reçoivent plus de public des
administrations chez qui il n'y a plus
d'accueil physique personnalisé juste un
robot au bout du fil au mieux un centre
d'appel où l'on passe des heures à
articuler des mots clés ou à taper un de
ou TR l'an dernier le Défenseur des
droits dénonçait la gravité de la
situation la dématérialisation étant
responsable de flagrantes ruptures de
droit des les dégâts sont considérables
combien de millions de nos compatriotes
sont-ils exclus aujourd'hui d'un accès
normal à nos administrations enfin les
maisons Fran servic qui devaient être la
solution au problème d'éloignement des
services publics la solution à toutes
les fermetures de services publics
demeure
insuffisante cet outil vanté aux élus
désespérés par la disparition des
administrations se révèle adapté
sous-financé par l'État avec des agents
précarisés insuffisamment formés comme
toutes les mesures alternatives elles ne
peuvent être présenté comme un progrès
mais bien comme une régression et en ce
sens nous vous rejoignons madame le
rapporteur alors rappelons-nous que le
président Emmanuel Macron avait déclaré
nos services publics devront porter
l'espérance en une vie meilleure c'est
tout le contraire et Julie Gervet mare
de conférence à l'Université Panthéon
Sorbonne dénonce la fermeture des
services publics qui créent une
souffrance de zonees déserté où les
habitants se sentent hors jeu et
humiliés je le crois fermement et pense
avec elle que la nouvelle gestion
publique le fameux new public management
a produit surtout le les mécanismes de
dégradation du service public l'accès au
service public chers collègues c'est
l'accès aux droits l'accès à ces droits
de citoyens le droit d'être aidé est
défendu mes chers collègues parce que
pour notre groupe il n'y a pas de souci
cy en France ni dans les campagnes ni
dans les cités la seule solution est
bien la réouverture des accueils
physiques dans tous les services publics
aussi comme 91 % des Français nous
sommes favorables à la réouverture des
accueils physiques dans les services
publicame je donne la parole à Monsieur
remerot inscrit sur l'article 1er madame
la présidente madame la ministre madame
le
rapporteur mes chers collègues d'abord
un regret mais il sera peut-être biô
compensé c'est l'absence de Monsieur
Bernal il tenait TS il y a 2
he à cette DG je ne le vois
pas je serais heureux qu'il soit là
parce que ah le voilà il tenait
temp en commission des
lois à ce moment j'aurais eu peur qu'il
passeil passa à
côté vous savez un seul êre vous manque
et tout est apaisé faut je voudrais
simplement madame auonau vous
remercier très
chaleureusement parce que votre texte
est un super hommage au grand débat à la
demande des maires et à l'écoute du
président Macron lorsqu'il a créé France
service avant les France services vous
aviez raison il y a eu un grand nombre
de fermetures d'accue ac physique un
échec de la numérisation pour de
nombreux accès au services public tout
cela était vrai depuis beaucoup de nos
concitoyens qui rencontrent des
difficultés ont pris l'habitude et les
chemins de France service le lien se
fait l'accompagnement et mieux et mieux
la formation à la administration car on
peut être tout à
fait adapté et être formé sur numérique
pour les jeux pour les vidéos et ne pas
être à l'aise avec la administration
comme je l'ai constaté c'est une affaire
de tous les âges et les France services
répondent à cela il y a encore sans
doute des améliorations à faire mais
nous sommes là pour en débattre nous ne
sommes plus en tout cas à cette époque-
làà et je veux rendre hommage au
personnel des Fran services à tous nos
concitoyens qui apprécient ces services
qui se déplacent qui les PLCI monsur
merci Madame auonau pour le bel hommage
que vous rendez à France service merci
et j'appelle l'amendement numéro 3 de
Madame la
rapporteur merci madame la Présidente
alors
je je vais profiter de cet amendement
pour donner quelqueses éléments de de
réponse mais je note que une très large
majorité des groupes de cette assemblée
ont convenu de l'intérêt d'avoir ce
débat aujourd'hui en séance et que dans
les interventions de la discussion
générale beaucoup de constats étaient
partagés sur l'intérêt du du numérique
j'y reviendrai la facilité que cela
signifie pour un certain nombre de nos
concitoyens et concitoyennes mais aussi
la reconnaissance des difficultés qui
qui perdurent et de la nécessité d'y
apporter un certain nombre de de
réponses je voulais rappeler ici qu'il y
a peut-être eu un mal entendu dans les
discussions que nous avons eu depuis le
début nous ne faisons pas une opposition
entre le numérique et le physique bien
au contraire je pense que vous le savez
depuis que notre groupe existe à
l'Assemblée nous sommes des utilisateurs
et des utilisatrices du numérique des
réseaux sociaux vous nous en faites
parfois même le reproche mais plus
généralement nous avons développer une
orientation et une stratégie par rapport
au numérique que nous considérons comme
un bien commun comm comme un des champs
une frontière de l'humanité dont il faut
s'emparer pour le mettre au service du
bien commun donc il ne s'agit nullement
de notre part d'une volonté de retour en
arrière nous ne croyons pas au cétait
mieux avant pas du tout chers collègues
rassurez-vous mais nous pensons que ça
peut être bien mieux encore et en
s'appuyant ce qui fait les fondements de
notre République et de la République
sociale et voilà le sens même de notre
proposition de loi qui d'une manière
effectivement je le reconnais collègue
de euh la macronie euh garantissent
quelque chose que vous avez vous-même
reconnu à travers la réouverture
d'accueil physique dans les France
servic que vous avez noté madame la
ministre en expliquant que il vait il
allait y avoir il était prévu des
réouvertures de sous-préfectures et donc
il s'agit tout simplement de donner
force par la loi à cette démarche que
vous avez engagé mais que nous voulons
national et que nous voulons consolider
par la loi pour que sur tout le
territoire cela ne dépende plus
simplement de des moyens des
collectivités qu'elle pourrait avoir et
surtout qu'il y ait une forme d'un
d'uniformisation de ces accueils
physiques parce que et c'est c'est un
des une des limites du modèle de France
service il y a une très grande diversité
et ça signifie aussi parfois une
inégalité dans les moyens qui sont
donnés à la fois pour les conseillers et
conseillères et et aussi pour les les
usagers et les usagères je viens
rapidement à notre amendement
pour renforcer en fait justement le les
garanties accordées par par ce cette loi
c'est inspiré notamment par les échanges
que nous avons eu au cours des des
auditions nous voulons faire en sorte
que les usagers et les usagères puissent
avoir une prise en charge en physique
dans un délai raisonnable c'est une
dimension cruciale parce que pour dans
de trop nombreux dans de dans un trop
grand nombre de cas excusez-moi les
situations notamment pour les personnes
les plus précaires peuvent devenir
extrêmement dramatiques quand elles
n'ont plus accès à leur droits que ce
soit des revenus que ce soit des
bénéficiaires du du chômage des
allocataires du RSA de la retraite que
ce soit des personnes étrangères pour
qui l'obtention d'un titre signifie une
question parfois de vie ou de mort il
nous semble que intégrer dans un dél
raisonnable euh cette cette notion
permettrait de garantir justement
d'avoir la meilleure efficacité de ce
service voilà le le sens de cet
amendement pour lequel à titre personnel
je donne un avis favorable et j'espère
que vous l'adopterez je vous remercie et
avant de donner la parole à madame la
ministre je vous informe que je suis
saisie de deux nouveaux scrutins publics
par le groupe Renaissance sur le vote de
l'amendement 4 et le vote de
l'amendement numéro 1 madame la ministre
pour votre avis sur cette amendement
numéro
3 madame la rapporteur donc les délais
tendent d' baisser même si des progrès
évidemment reste à faire toute la
politique omnicanal s'oriente
effectivement vers cet objectif
desengorger les guichets permettre aux
agents de se concentrer aux usagers qui
en ont le plus besoin l'augmentation du
recours de rendez-vous en accueil vous
avez raison physique au téléphone est
d'ailleurs une priorité et il me semble
que le ministre Stanislas Guerini l'a
rappelé plusieurs fois une priorité du
gouvernement l'objectif évidemment de
faciliter la vie la vie des usagers donc
je donne mon avis tout de suite madame
la Présidente sagesse sur cet amendement
merci Madame la Ministre avis de sagesse
madame e vous avez la
parole merci madame la Présidente je
dois dire que cette PPL donne énormément
de satisfaction à la majorité je suis
ravie que nous ayons réussi à vous
convaincre mes chers collègues de l' de
l'hémicycle à gauche puisqu'il y a
encore quelques années vous nous disiez
que France service était
finalement un masque au manque de
service public finalement ça devient à
vos yeux un vrai service de proximité
des services publics qui reviennent en
force dans nos territoires et je profite
de cette prise de parole pour rendre
hommage un hommage appuyé à Jacqueline
gourau qui était ministre de la cohésion
des territoires et des collectivités et
de relations avec les collectivités
territoriales qui a porté à bout de bras
ce programme et quand j'étais à ses
côtés nous avions un certain nombre de
nos collègues qui réclamaient une seule
chose l'ouverture d'une maison France
service dans son territoire donc ce cet
amendement de madame bobonau je crois
qu'il est bienvenu parce
qu'effectivement il ça précise la PPL ça
donne encore plus de force à la volonté
que nous avons de répondre vite et bien
euh à la demande de nos concitoyens sur
les services publics donc je crois que
effectivement nous devrions adopter cet
amendement juste une petite précision et
peut-être un petit point de désaccord
avec ce que vous avez dit les maisons
France service ne doivent pas être
uniformisées parce qu'elles doivent
s'adapt à leur territoire les besoins
dans le monde rural ne sont pas les
mêmes que les besoins en péri urbains ou
des dans dans des grandes zones urbaines
donc laissons les collectivités les
associations les services publics
s'organiser au mieux pour répondre aux
besoins des territoires merci pour
l'hommage que vous avez rendu à cette
majorité surtout à Jacqueline
gourau
merci Monsieur
serva merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues ben écoutez c'est pour aussi
saluer cette très belle initiative
notamment concernant les territoires
ultramarins il ne vous a pas échappé
qu'il y a des zones blanches un peu
partout et que effectivement lorsqu'on
demande de faire du numérique s'il n'y a
pas de possibilité de se connecter à
Internet ça ne fonctionne pas d'autant
plus que dans les territoires d'où je
viens Guadeloupe Martinique la
population est vieillissante et on a
parfois de l'électronisme et forcément
cette situation qui permet de
compenser ce blocage lié au manque de
numérique et aussi au vieillissement de
la population est extrêmement bienvenu
donc c'est une excellente chose je vous
remercie nous allons procéder au scrutin
public sur cet amendement numéro 3 je
vous rappelle l'avis défavorable de la
commission favorable à titre personnel
de la rapporteur et avis de sagesse du
gouvernement le scrutin est
[Applaudissements]
ouvert le scrutin est
clos résultat votant 148 exprimés 130
majorité 66 pour 121 contre 9
l'Assemblée nationale a
adopté
nous en venons à l'amendement numéro
4 de Monsieur Reay est seul signataire
seul signataire donc il tombe
l'amendement numéro 4 tombe je donne la
parole à Madame la rapporteur pour
l'amendement numéro 2
oui merci madame la
Présidente
alors cet amendement aborde un sujet qui
qui me semble
extrêmement
important celui de la formation des
agentes et des agents en charge de ces
services publics cela est vrai pour
notamment les agences France servic et
nous n'avons aucun mal à noter et c'est
ce que j'ai dit dans dans ma discussion
générale que d'une certaine manière
c'était la reconnaissance de ce que nous
disions aussi de la nécessité d'un
accueil physique et quand on peut
converger dans l'intérêt général de la
population c'est tant mieux mais il y a
effectivement et dans ce cas précis un
certain nombre de limites ça a été
d'ailleurs relevé dans les uditions que
nous avons pu avoir avec les
responsables de l'Agence nationale de la
cohision des territoires
avec également les agents chargés de la
transition du numérique sur le fait que
le niveau de formation des conseillers
et des conseillères par exemple de
France service était parfois insuffisant
il était très court et qui avait
notamment la nécessité d'augmenter ce
temps de formation mais de manière
général y compris pour les agents des
autres services publics des organismes
sociaux qui sont concernés par l'accueil
du public qui doit réouvrir il est
fondamental que ces agents soient formés
à un accueil un accueil global que ce
soit sur y compris eux-mêmes la gestion
des outils numériques parce que à chaque
renouvellement des logiciels ça crée de
la difficulté et y compris ça crée pour
les agents des charges de travail
supplémentaires parce que ces logiciels
ne sont pas toujours suffisamment pensé
y compris avec les agents et les agentes
en question bref que ce soit d'un côté
ou l'autre des guichets il nous semble
que la question de la formation est
fondamentale voilà pourquoi nous je
propose que soit indiquée la nécessité
de parcours de de formation
convenablement dimensionné financé et
adapté aux impératifs et primètres de
l'exercice de
l'accueil merci Madame la rapporteur
madame la
ministre madame la rapporteur donc les
agents publics ont effectivement un
droit à la formation tout au long de
leur carrière de plus sur le cas
particulier de France service la
formation des agents je me permets juste
de le rappeler est désormais de 11 jours
et demi de plus les agents des
administrations qui sont dans le
programme service plus sont formés en ce
sens l'objectif est d'améliorer la
qualité de service aux usagers mettant
les agents en capacité de tenir leur
rôle grâce à la formation principe de
symétrie des attentions je prends soin
de l'usage AG et de l'agent pour se
faire l'agent dispose dans un espace qui
lui est propre d'un programme de
ressources de formation cet amendement
est déjà satisfait mais je je mets un
avis de
sagesse avis de sagesse merci madame la
ministre monsieur la
baronne merci Madame la la présidente
alors nous parlons beaucoup des des
maisons France service et c'est vrai que
c'est un un hommage rendu à l'action euh
euh du président de la République et de
Jacqueline gourau euh sous l'ancienne
mandature mais moi je voudrais insister
peut-être sur deux points si vous me le
permettez d'abord souligner l'extrême
diversité des lieux d'implantation des
maisons Frances et cette diversité
d'implantation permet d'aller au plus
près de nos concitoyens par exemple moi
dans ma circonscription j'ai une maison
France service dans un centre
socioc-ulturel dans les locaux de la
Communauté de Commune Bléré val-de-cher
dont j'été vice-président
j'ai une maison Fran service dans des
sous-préfectures dans des véhicules
mobiles et je pense à la communauté de
comen Touren est vallée vousvrez
Montlouis je voudrais par ailleurs
rappeler qu'il y a une diversité
d'accueil physique à la fois à travers
les conseillers numériques mais
également à travers les
services les services ah ben je retrouve
plus le terme je vais je vais retrouver
euh
et oui les s'agissant des des maisons
franc service je crois qu'il y a un
point que nous n'avons pas
signalé ce point c'est
que quand nous avons travaillé dans le
cadre de l'injada rural s'agissant des
maisons France service nous avons
rappelé que les premiers les premiers de
front pour répondre à nos concitoyens
s'agissant des services publics c'était
les mairies et là je m'étonne qu'on ne
me parle pas
éond attentes de concitoy en matière de
service public voilà alors s'agissant de
la formation des secrétaires de mairie
ou s'agissant des agents qui travaillent
dans les maisons franc service c'est
vrai qu'il faut faire un effort de
formation mais je crois que cet effort
est fait dans le cadre des centres de
gestion départementaux merci beaucoup je
vous
remercie la parole est à Madame Blin
merci Présidente je pense que votre
amendement madame la rapporteur est
l'illustration d'une loi bavarde je
pense que il n'est pas nécessaire de le
rajouter à ce niveau dans dans le débat
mais simplement moi ce que je voudrais
dire c'est que évidemment qu'il nous
faut dans nos campagnes dans nos
différents services publics une un
accueil physique parce qu'effectivement
c'est de plus en plus compliqué
aujourd'hui pour nos concitoyens d'avoir
accès à nos services publics ceci étant
au-delà de l'accès il est profondément
question de la nécessaire simplification
parce que rien ne ser
si l'administration reste toujours aussi
complexe et incompréhensible donc bien
au-delà de l'accueil physique qui est
encore une fois je le redis nécessaire
il faut aussi que le gouvernement
s'engage à simplifier les démarches
administratives Madame le Ministre ça
pas l'air de l'intéresser la question de
simplification pour les usagers et pour
les particuliers Bruno Le Maire a
annoncé mais on le sait à chaque fois
qu'on parle de simplification on
complexifie pour les les entreprises une
une étape de simplification mais à quel
niveau l'administration française votre
ministère madame la ministre pourrait
prendre des engagements non mais vous
représentez aujourd'hui au banc le le
gouvernement donc j'imagine que vous
êtes quand même compétente pour nous
donner un certain nombre d'éléments vous
pouvez nous rapporter un certain nombre
d'éléments intéressants apportés à notre
connaissance à la connaissance de la
représentation nationale en matière de
simplification pour nos
citoyens je vous
remercie je vais donc mettre au voix C
amendement
numéro numéro 2
oui numéro 2 je rappelle l'avis
défavorable de la commission favorable à
titre personnel de la rapporteur sagesse
du gouvernement merci de regagner vos
places le scrutin est
ouvert le scrutin est
clos résultat votant 153 exprimé 141
majorité 71 pour 120 contre 21
l'Assemblée nationale a
adopté nous en venons à l'amendement
numéro 1 sur lequel il y aura également
un scrutin public à la demande du groupe
Renaissance le scrutin est annoncé
madame Ménard vous avez la
parole merci madame la Présidente alors
je vous l'ai dit en en commission je
suis pas du tout opposé au numérique
bien au contraire parce qu'il facilite
évidemment la vie des Français et il
diminue notamment les déplacements ce
qui est bon pour l'empreinte carbone de
notre planète et vous devriez y être
très sensible mais il est vrai que j'ai
pu constater chez certaines personnes et
notamment les plus âgés des difficultés
parfois à accéder aux services publics
alors mon amendement est un amendement
d'efficacité et il prévoit que les
maisons France servic pour assurer un
accueil physique opérant des service
publics peuvent avoir recours au
servicees CIVI alors en commission un de
vos députés m'avait répondu que ce
n'était pas autorisé alors je vois pas
très bien pourquoi puisque les services
civiques peuvent travailler dans les
préfectures donc pourquoi il pourrait
pas travailler dans les maisons France
service du coup je suis allée vérifier
et j'ai évidemment trouvé ceci le
service civique est un engagement
volontaire pour assurer des missions
d'intérêt général répondant aux besoins
de la population et des territoires
les employeurs dans la fonction publique
vont s'appuyer sur des volontaires des
volontaires en service civique pour
tester des actions socialement
innovantes alors les services civiques
peuvent travailler dans 10 domaines
d'action différents dont le domaine de
la solidarité ou celui de la citoyenneté
bref il me paraisse parfaitement adapté
à l'amélioration de l'accueil physique
dans nos services publics et j'espère
donc que contrairement à ce que vous
avez fait en commission vous voterez mon
amendement je vous remercie merci Madame
Ménard madame la rapporteur que l'on
écoute dans le calme merci merci madame
la Présidente alors malheureusement
madame Ménard je ne suis pas favorable à
cet amendement comme je vous les ai dit
les services civiques ont effectivement
une utilité et c'est une manière pour
beaucoup de jeunes de s'engager et
d'être sensibilisé à un certain nombre
de problématiques mais malheureusement
un des problèmes ça a été l'usage massif
de ces contrats services civiques qui
ont trop souvent été utilisés pour
remplacer justement des postes de de
fonctionnaires euh et euh il me semble
que ce n'est pas du tout l'usage qu'il
devrait avoir euh nous avons adopté un
amendement qui visait à ce que il y ait
de la formation parce que accueillir des
des usagers et des usagères c'est un
métier aussi et qu'il faut pouvoir faire
en sorte que y compris les personnes qui
sont chargé de l'accueil ne soit pas
elle-même en difficulté pour répondre
aux besoins des usagers et donc il me
semble que c'est une très très très
mauvaise idée ça va à l'encontre
justement de l'amélioration du service
public et de l'accueil dont on a besoin
et donc comme la commission qui a donné
un avis défavorable je maintiens cet
avis défavorable merci Madame la
rapporteur madame la ministre merci euh
donc cet amendement madame cet
amendement est satisfait en effet les
organismes publics peuvent déjà avoir
recours aux jeunes service CIVI nous
comprenons l'objet de cet amendement
mais c'est plus de l'ordre de la
pratique demande de retrait donc ou
défavorable je vous remercie madame
claapo merci madame la Présidente donc
je voudrais à mon tour rendre hommage
aux médiateurs aux conseillers aux
aidanss à tous ceux qui dans les
différents France servic que ça soit
dans les bureaux de poste dans les
collectivités locales dans les locaux
des association apporte ce service aussi
important et vous avez raison il faut de
l'humain car le numérique même sil
apporte te beaucoup d'automatisation et
s'il simplifie la tâche il ne peut pas
se passer de d'une médiation humaine
mais moi je voudrais à l'occasion de cet
amendement m'élever peut-être contre une
certaine tendance je mets des guillemets
au jeunisme car il n'y a pas que les
personnes jeunes qui peuvent exercer ce
métier de médiateur numérique et à
l'heure où nous voulons revaloriser le
travail des seniors je voudrais que dans
ces France servic et dans tous ces lieux
où on on a des médiateurs numériques
qu'on fasse aussi appel à des personnes
un petit peu plus proches de la retraite
parce qu'elles ont l'expérience elles
ont la maturité elles ont la pédagogie
elles ont l'empathie et je voudrais
aussi en profiter pour dire que les
femmes seniores ne sont pas assez
présentes dans les métier du numérique
donc j'aimerais beaucoup et je suis
contre cet amendement j'aimerais
beaucoup qu'à cette occasion on rende
hommage et qu'on suscite des vocations
de médiateurs numériques qui soient des
seniors et qui soient des
femmes
madame clapo madame Grangier a la parole
merci madame la Présidente écoutez moi
je suis très très inquiète quand
j'entend qu'il faut mettre des services
civiques pour remplacer des
professionnels en tant qu'assistante
sociale j'ai travaillé durant 20 ans et
durant 20 ans j'ai soutenu des personnes
qui se retrouvaient régulièrement en
difficulté pour accéder à leurs droits
et durant les durant ces dernières
années cette situation s'est aggravée
car nous n'avions plus d'Inter loocuteur
nous ce que nous demandons ce sont des
professionnels qui puissent répondre à
des questions qui qui puissent répondre
à finalement à des questions et des
problématiques qui se complexifient de
plus en plus si on veut rendre un
service public de qualité il faut qu'il
soit adapté aux personnes avec des
professionnels formés et et non pas des
services civies alors nous nous
abstiendrons je vous remercie
nous procédons au scrutin public sur cet
amendement numéro 1 qui a obtenu un avis
défavorable de la rapporteur et
défavorable du gouvernement le scrutin
est
ouvert le scrutin est
clos résultat du scrutin votant 196
exprimé 174 majorité 88 pour 9 contre
165 l'Assemblée nationale n'a pas
adopté nous poursuivons et je vous
informe que sur le vote de l'amendement
7 nous onons également un scrutin public
à la demande du groupe Renaissance le
scrutin est donc
annoncé alors nous en venons un
amendement numéro 5 monsieur Gouffier
Vallante oui merci madame la
Présidente revenir sur la stratégie de
modernisation et transformation
numérique des services publics pour
garantir un accueil physique en toutes
circonstances et un droit opposable pour
les usagers comme le propose la présente
proposition de loi implique un
bouleversement de l'organisation des
administrations et de l'état un délai
d'application des dispositions est donc
nécessaire et donc je propose de
reporter cette disposition au 1er
janvier
2032 sachant que les amendements
suivants seront sur un repli à 2000 à
2030 et 2028 je vous remci c'est là
merci Monsieur Gouffier Valante alors
madame la rapporteur sur ces amendements
de
durée euh oui merci madame la Présidente
je vais donner du coup un avis sur les
amendements 5 6 7 dans la foulée
puisqu'il s'agit du même type
d'amendement qui vise à repousser la
mise en application de de la loi je
crois que nous sommes tous convenus de
la nécessité de l'importance de garantir
cet accès physique et je ne crois pas
qu'il y ait de Rais
pour le repousser aussi tard pour
énormément de nos concitoyens et
concitoyennes c'est une urgence au jour
le jour et si nous sommes d'accord sur
sur ce constat on ne veut le repousser
aussi loin donc je demande de retrait
sinon avis défavorable pour la
rapporteur comme ça a été le cas pour la
commission la rapporteur madame la
ministre monsieur le député donc j'ai eu
l'occasion de l'aborder l de la
discussion générale mais ce texte est à
rebours de la stratégie qui est la notre
et semble décorrilé de la réalité son
entrée en vigueur en 2032 paraît
compréhensible tant l'adoption de la
proposition de loi serait à l'opposé de
l'action menée depuis plusieurs années
néanmoins j' mettrai un avis de
sagesse je vous
remercie alors madame la rapporteur
juste pour qu'on soit clair c'est un
avis défavorable sur le 5 et le 6 et le
7 et Madame la min
minist madame la ministre c'est un avis
de sagesse sur les TR ou ou uniquement
sur le
5 sagesse sur les trois sagesse sur les
trois je vous remercie donc les droit
les trois ont été défendus monsieur
coufier Valente je crois les trois
d'accord donc je vais prendre plusieurs
prises de parole puisque les trois ont
été défendus j'ai madame e j'ai monsieur
mournet J'ai madame Grangier ça fera
trois pour trois amendements madame e
oui
merci madame la Présidente je ne voulais
pas prendre la parole mais quand j'ai
écouté madame Grangier s'exprimer sur
les maisons France service et sur les
services civies qui
sont employé dans les services civiques
je me pose la question si vous avez déjà
mis les pieds dans une maison France
service et si vous avez déjà rencontré
des jeunes qui sont au service civique
quelle est la mission première d'un
service civique la mission première d'un
service c'est de mener une mission
d'intérêt général quelle est quelle
meilleure mission d'intérêt général que
celle de rendre service justement à nos
concitoyens en étant dans un service
public de proximité il ne se non mais
attendez c'est pas la peine de faire des
sauts de pu mes chers collègues du
rassemblement national écoutez comment
comment ça se passe réellement dans une
maison France service les services
civies sont là pour appuyer pour aider
pour orienter pour informer il ne se
substitu pas à l'agent qui se qui qui
est employé par la maison France service
donc je sais bien que vous essayez de
trouver des choses à redire sur un
service qui fonctionne bien qui est
plébisité par toutes les collectivités
territoriales y compris cell qui se
trouvent dans vos circonscription et
bien souffrez que nous répondions de
manière précise efficace avec de la
dentelle au services public dont sont
droit à attendre nos concitoyens je vous
remercie madame E
monsie monsieur monouret a la parole sur
l'amendement les
amendements merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre madame la rapporteur
chers collègues je crois que notre
majorité est crédible sur le réarmement
des services publics dans la police dans
la justice la gendarmerie l'école la
santé et je vais même vous faire une
confidence c'est la raison pour laquelle
je me suis engagé en politique c'est le
cœur de mon engagement c'est le cœur de
notre engagement et cette proposition de
loi n'est pas inintéressante mais au
fond elle vient un peu validé en partie
ce que nous avons fait en particulier
avec le souci d'aller au premier ou au
dernier kilomètre à travers les maisons
Fran service plus de 2500 et je me
réjouis cette semaine d'avoir appris
l'ouverture de celle à à lu sa Sauveur
ne pas opposer vous nous avez rassurer
numérique et accueil physique parce que
le numérique est un formidable
accélérateur d'accès au servic public
mais évidemment nous tous dans nos
circonscriptions combien de fois
sommes-nous interpellés pour aider nos
concitoyens à faire des démarches
l'enjeu donc c'est justement qu'il y ait
des conseillers numériques des
médiateurs pour aider y compris à faire
les démarches en ligne c'est ce que nous
faisons vous nous avez rassuré sur le
fait que vous npposiez pas que vous avez
pas une forme de nostalgie du passé à
ces conditions-là je trouve que ce texte
n'est pas
inintéressant je vous remercie cet
amendement peut-être l'amendement numéro
7 je serai favorable merci à vous je
vous remercie et Madame Grangier merci
madame la Présidente bien nous voterons
contre les trois amendements parce que
je pense qu'il y a aussi urgence pour
que l'on vienne en soutien à nos
services publics alors ces maisons
France service dont on parle si voilà si
bien dont on en fait l'éloge finalement
c'est quoi elles viennent remplacer les
services publics qui petit à petit ont
disparu dans nos cités dans nos
campagnes
elles ont été remplacées elles ont
pardon
remplacé finalement les départs en
retraite que nous ne finançons pas que
nous ne finançons plus ces
fonctionnaires qui ne seront pas
remplacés ce sont des fonctionnaires CAF
des fonctionnaires CQ des fonctionnaires
MSA et d'autres encore et bien on les
remplace par des maisons France service
alors oui nous ne souhaitons pas opposer
non plus numérique et service public
parce qu'effectivement la
dématérialisation apporte une plus-value
mais pas seulement elle elle provoque
aussi un profond malaise dans notre
société et nous avons aujourd'hui des
Français qui ont un service public
lowcost ce qu'il faut rappeler aussi
c'est que les serv les maisons France
service elles coûtent elles coûtent aux
communes enfin elles coûtent pardon euh
1100 € par an finalement sur ces 110000
€ par an l'état n'en finance que 30000
c'est donc à la charge des collectivités
de financer le reste alors oui payons à
bas coup des des ouvriers des salariés
des fonctionnaires payons les à Bacou
mais réellement c'est est-ce que c'est
ce service public là que nous souhaitons
pour les Français et bien nous nous ne
nous disons non nous voulons un
véritable service public un service
public où les personnes peuvent être
entendues réellement même si elles ne
rentre pas dans les cases et c'est bien
ça le problème parce que même si on
finance des jeunes pour les des jeunes
qui viennent du service civique et bien
même s'ils sont en capacité
d'accompagner les gens pour dans la
dématérialisation si les gens ne
rentrent pas dans les cases ils n'auront
personne et aucune réponse en facee de
mê mercici Mad rangier
merci amendement numéro 11 monsieur
Gouffier valallante oui merci madame la
Présidente demande une nouvelle fois de
rapport dans un délai d'un an une
demande de rapport sur l'impact de la
dématérialisation des démarches sur
l'efficacité le délai de traitement des
demandes du Trésor public je vous
remercie alors je vous
remercie je vous remercie je je prends
la vie de Madame la rapporteur qui avait
dit tout à l'heure me semble-t-il
favorable à titre personnel sur celui-ci
donc c'est défavorable commission et
favorable titre personnel madame la
ministre je suis de bonne humeur ce
soir donc si vous me permettez je vais
faire une petite explication de texte ça
permettra de remettre donc je
l'expliquer là c'est la trème fois lors
du dernier CITP de mai 2023 dans le
cadre de service public plus il a été
décidé de mettre en place le tableau de
bord de suivi de qualité des services
rendus aux usagers par les
administrations donc je vous épargne le
reste
et cet article enfin cet amendement est
satisfait
et désolé ça sera
sagesse je vous remercie c'est donc un
avis de sagesse comme j'ai plus de deux
demandes de prise de parole je prends un
pour et je prends un contre comme je
fais toujours donc je donne la parole a
priori on va voir si ça se confirme à
monsieur
saintoule nous sommes pour vous êtes
pour
absolument ben
[Musique]
allez-y
d'accord alors donc
j'ai Monsieur Henry allez-y vous êtes
pour également oui madame la Présidente
contre avec simplement un argumentaire
effectivement pour appuyer la demande de
de rapport problème sur sur ce sujet
peut-être simplement un un point
d'explication complémentaire pour aussi
remettre en perspective l'importance de
la mutualité sociale agricole la MSA qui
fait un travail formidable en lien avec
les maisons Fran service notamment pour
le public éloigné du monde rural de nos
agricul que sont nos agriculteurs je
pense que c'est important également de
le souligner on aurait peut-être pu
également le le rajouter au sein de au
sein de cette demande de de rapport et
je pense qu'on l'a tous pu constater euh
c'est c'est mon cas notamment sur les
maisons euh France service de chaill et
les marais par exemple qui se situe euh
dans le dans le marépois de vin dont on
évoquait tout à l'heure et et et Don les
rapports s'il vous plaît mes chers
collègues et et dont les rapports avec
la MSA devraient aussi être mis en en
perspective dans dans le même cadre que
cette demande de de rapport pour qu'on
puisse continuer à faire en sorte
d'avoir un service de proximité pour ce
public souvent très éloigné de nos nos
services publics je et je pense que tous
les agriculteurs compteront sur le
gouvernement à l'avenir pour continuer à
à influencer et faire en sorte que les
maisons français
puisse continuer à à porter l'ensemble
de ces services publics dans nos
territoires
merci
merci nous procédons scrutin public
amendement numéro 11 avis défavorable de
la commission favorable à titre
personnel de la rapporteur et av de
sagesse du gouvernement le scrutin est
ouvert le scrutin est
clos
résultat votant 197 exprimé 170 majorité
86 pour 164 contre 6 l'Assemblée
nationale a
adopté amendement numéro 12 monsieur
Goufi
Valente nouvelle madame la Présidente
nouvelle demande de rapport sur l'impact
cette fois-ci de la dématérialisation
des démarches sur l'efficacité le délai
de traitement des demandes des bureau de
poste je vous remercie alors tout à
l'heure l'avis favorable à tit personnel
de Madame la rapporteur oui et
défavorable de la commission madame la
ministre pour l'avis du
gouvernement pour Rael donc la poste
n'est plus une
administration si depuis
1991 le dernier contrat
d'entreprise je je monsieur Rin s'il
vous plaît qui parle de
respect ah ben je suis là non mais je
suis là je vous réponds merciy merci
monsieur le député pour rappel donc la
poste n'est plus une administration
depuis
1991 le dernier contrat d'État la Poste
a été signée a été signé le 26 juin 2023
ce contrat l'îétat à la poste pour
quatre missions de service public le
service universel postal la contribution
à l'aménagement du territoire le
transport et la distribution de la
presse et l'accessibilité bancaire dans
ce cadre les objectifs de qualité
d'efficacité les modalités de suivi ont
été définies et sont régulièrement
documenté il n'est donc pas utile de
compléter ce
dispositif donc c'est un avis c'est une
demande de retrait ou
défavorable je vous remercie alors j'ai
madame la Présidente panneau merci
madame la Présidente notre groupe votera
pour merci madame la Présidente alors
oui madame oui madame Rila qui
effectivement avait demandé la parole
tout à l'heure oui sur le sur
l'amendement juste
avant mais vous êtes favorable vous êtes
pour ou contre l'amendement j'entends
pas Madame oui favorable aussi donc oui
elle aussi trois prises de parole madame
la Présidente Panau a dit pour elle a
pas défendu donc je donne la parole à
Madame rilac merci ben oui merci madame
la Présidente non simplement pour parler
euh
oui poursuivez madame RAC pour ce pour
parler de cette administration qui est
devenue la poste pour m'inscrire en faux
sur ce qui a été dit tout à l'heure sur
les les bancs du rassemblement national
parce que justement la Poste est le
parfait contre-exemple oui en effet sur
mon territoire qui est en effet péri
urbain il y a eu des fermetures
régulières des postes et
particulièrement des postes annexes et
grâce à la mise en place des maisons
Fran services et bien il y a eu un
recrutement DESP tier qui grâce à la
formation dont madame obono a parlé
d'ailleurs dans l'article 1er et bien
ils ont pu se mettre au service de leurs
concitoyens à nouveau dans le cadre des
maisons France service apportant deux
services très
importants un accompagnement au
numérique et un service de proximité qui
a évité la fermeture des bureaux de
poste je vous
remercie scrutin public amendement
numéro 12 favorable de la commission
favorable à titre personnel de Madame la
rapporteur défavorable du gouvernement
le scrutin est
ouvert le scrutin est
clos résultat votant 194 exprimés 167
majorités 84 pour 161 contre 6
l'Assemblée nationale a
adopté amendement numéro 13 monsieur
bouffiervent merci madame la Présidente
dernière demande de de rapport au
gouvernement toujours dans un délai d'un
mois toujours sur l'impact de la
dématérialisation des démarches sur
l'efficacité et le délai de traitement
des demandes des
préfectures sujet qui nous a grandement
par ailleurs occupé dans le projet de
loi immigration ces derniers jours je
vous remercie merci Madame la
rapporteur sur le numéro 13 défavorable
ycpris à titre personnel sur celui-ci
d'accord madame la ministre
merci madame la Présidente donc lors du
dernier CITP
201223 dans le casadre de service public
plus il a été décidé de mettre en place
le tableau de bord de suivi de la
qualité des services rendus aux usagés
par les administrations publiques ce
tableau de bord comporte C indicateurs
de ressenti satisfaction globale délai
de traitement accessibilité simplicité
des démarches qualité de la relation
mesurer par sondage à la maille
nationale et régionale et inclut le taux
de qualité des démarches en ligne il
permet de suivre l'impact de toute
action dans la dématérialisation sur la
qualité de l'ensemble des services
publics les préfectures font partie des
administrations suivies il donc pas
utile de financer encore un rapport
supplémentaire pour traiter cette
demande qui a déjà été prise en compte
donc ce sera une demande de retrait ou
un avis
défavorable merci madame la ministre
monsieur de Logu oui merci merci madame
la Présidente donc notre groupe votre
raconte puisque comme le dit Madame la
Ministre on a déjà les chiffres donc ce
ce rapport ne sert à rien
merci merci Monsieur
mournet merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre madame la rapporteur
moi je serais favorable à cet amendement
de notre collègue Guillaume
gouffiervante parce que c'est aussi une
occasion de mettre en lumière le travail
de terrain de proximité difficile de nos
agents de préfecture auquel on pense peu
c'est un rapport qui pourrait venir
éclairer utilement nos débats que nous
aurons sur le projet de loi immigration
je voudrais dire que les préfectures
adoptent la Charte Marianne que les
délais de traitement dans
les les services de de de droits des
étrangers c'est'est considérablement
amélioré et c'est un secteur où il est
bien difficile de concilier l'accueil
physique et numérique donc je pense que
ce rapport pourrait être utile merci
merci alors comme ça arrive vite je vous
annonce deux autres scrutins publics sur
l'amendement 14 à la demand du groupe
Renaissance et sur l'ensemble de la
proposition de loi à la demande du
groupe Renaissance et du groupe la
France insoumise les scrutins sont
annoncés et donc scrutin public sur cet
amendement numéro 13 double avis dé
favorable de la commission et du
gouvernement sur cet amendement le
scrutin est
ouvert le scrutin est
clos
résultat votant 197 exprimé 170
majorités 86 pour 69 contre 101
l'Assemblée nationale n'a pas
adopté et donc nous en arrivons à
l'article 2 madame e a la parole sur
l'article 2
oui merci madame la Présidente je prends
la parole sur cet article 2 pour dire
que le groupe Renaissance votera pour la
levée du gage parce qu'il faut bien
rappeler que tout cela n'est pas gratuit
depuis la mise en service de ces maisons
France service c'est près de 80 millions
d'euros qui sont consacrés à ce service
de proximité à nos concitoyens et donc
oui évidemment il faut lever le gage je
profite de cette prise de parole pour
rendre un hommage appuyé au réseau
associatif le réseau pys qui a été
précurseur qui œuvre depuis des années
j'ai même envie de vous dire des
décennies pour apporter plus de services
publics dans nos territoires et qui ont
vu depuis des années le retrait des
services publics comme quoi ce n'est pas
un fait de depuis 2007 c'est bien
antérieur à cette date-là et donc ils
ont pris le sujet à bras le corp et
aujourd'hui sont reconnus comme étant un
acteur incontournable du déploiement des
risau des réseaux maison France service
moi j'ai juste envie de dire à à
certains collègues qui restent encore
pas enfin pas convaincu euh de de de
l'utilité de ce service de proximité
j'ai juste envie de vous dire qui n'a
pas reçu dans sa permanence euh des
usagers des habitants qui n'arrivent pas
à remplir leurs documents qui sont de
fait
dématérialisés depuis bien
évidemment des des des des décennies et
bien avec ce réseau France service vous
allez pouvoir les orienter vers un
réseau qui va prendre en charge leurs
demande qui va les les les accom ag et
qui va surtout leur donner accès à des
conseillers numériques qui vont
permettre là aussi d'apporter un soutien
et l'accompagnement nécessaire à nos
concitoyens merci madame auonau de
reconnaître que ce que cette mesure qui
a été prise et décidé par le Président
de la République Emmanuel Macron et bien
est attendu plébiscité et reconnu par
les collègues de la gauche merci encore
je vous remercie
Madame et c'est scrtin
sur cet article 2 scrutin
public le scrutin est ouvert sur
l'article
2 le scrutin est
clos résultat votant 198 exprimé 172
majorité
87 s'il vous plaît pour 149 contre 23
l'Assemblée nationale a
adopté
s'il vous plaît nous sommes à la fin du
texte merci alors nous en venons aux
amendement au titre avec un amendement
madame S s'il vous plaît merci
amendement 14 monsieur s'il vous plaît
je vous remercie monsieur de merci deux
fois alors Monsieur Gouffier Valente
défendu madame la
rapporteur oui je vais donner un avis
sur les deux amendements de changement
titre je pense re estair etrespond ex à
ce qu'il faut ce que demand les
associations la Défenseur des droits le
Conseil d'État depuis de très nombreuses
années et donc je donne un avis
défavorable sur les deux amendements
comme la
commission merci Madame la
Ministre merci madame la Présidente donc
je comprends l'objet de cet amendement
en effet la PPL crée un droit opposable
à l'accueil physique qui ne nous paraît
ni efficient ni opérant l'heure où nous
centralisons les démarches néanmoins
j'émettrai un avis de sagesse ne
souhaitant pas empiéter sur le titre
d'un texte d'initiative
parlementaire je vous remercie sagesse
du gouvernement madame
Amrani non
d'accord monsieur la
baronne merci madame la Présidente je
voudrais s'il vous plaît je peux
m'exprimer
merci non non mais attendez une seconde
moi je voudrais quand même à la fin de
ce débat remercier tous les agents qui
travaillent dans les maisons franc
service et qui
représentent la caisse d'allocation
familiale le ministère de
l'intérieur de la justice des finances
publiques la Caisse nationale
d'assurance maladie la caisse la
mutualité sociale agricole la Caisse
nationale l'assurance vieillesse pô
emploi et la poste ce sont des agents
bien physiques ils sont présents dans
les maisons France service et je crois
que nous devons leur rendre hommage je
vous
remercie scrutin public sur l'amendement
numéro
14 qui a obtenu un avis défavorable de
la commission et un avis de sagesse du
gouvernement le scrutin est
ouvert
le scrutin est
clos résultat votant 203 exprimé 172
majorité 87 pour 69 contre 103
l'Assemblée nationale n'a pas
adopté monsieur Gouffier valent pour le
15 s'il vous plaît il est défendu merci
Madame la rapporteur défavorable madame
la
ministre prend l'objet de cet amendement
monsieur le député je rejoins le message
que vous souhaitez faire passer en
expliquant que la stratégie pour les
services publics développé par ce texte
est à l'opposé des ambitions du
gouvernement pour accélérer les
démarches auprès des usagers et
recentrer le travail des agents auprès
de ceux qui nécessite le plus
d'accompagnement néanmoins j'émettrai un
avis de sagesse pour les mêmes raisons
que tout à l'heure je vous remercie
merci madame la
ministre je mets au voix cet amendement
numéro 15 avis défavorable de la
commission et sagesse du gouvernement à
main levée qui est
pour qui est contre
ouais excusez-moi
je je n'ai pas le compat dans l'œil ce
soir donc je vais
compter
donc on va je vais refaire dans l'ordre
qui est
[Musique]
pour
merci et qui est
contre
[Musique]
alors je lis deux fois les les résultats
l'amendement n'est pas
adopté voilà
bon je suis saisie d'explication de vote
sur la proposition de loi avant de
passer au scrutin public la parole est à
Monsieur serva pour le groupe liberté
indépendant outremire et territoire
alors très court madame la Présidente
oui excellente initiative parce que nous
dans les outre ma nous souffrons de
désirs médicaux dans certains
territoires nous souffrons de
vieillissement de la population et nous
avons besoin d'une complémentarité entre
le numérique bien évidemment et le
physique et d'ailleurs ça relève aussi
de l'humain et de l'humanité du contact
donc trois fois oui à cette proposition
de loi excellente de
obono merci Monsieur
serva monsieur Gouffier valallent pour
le groupe
Renaissance merci Madame
la
Présidente je tenais à m'exprimer parce
que le groupe Renaissance a évolué sur
sa position comme vous l'aurez deviné
suite aux échanges à la fois les
échanges tenus en commission les
échanges qui ont pu avoir lieu entre la
Commission et la séance plus que les
échange que nous avons pu avoir durant
la séance nous n'allons pas vous le
cacher et donc nous nous orientons vers
un vote au fond d'abstention
d'abstention qui ne reniit en rien la
politique que nous menons et et les mots
que j'ai pu avoir au nom du
groupe durant la discussion générale
aussi bien sur la politique de présence
territoriale et d'accès au services
publics diversifiés que nous menons
aujourd'hui aussi bien sur les accueils
physiques que sur le développement du
numérique d'autres outils qui permettent
bien entendu à l'ensemble de nos
concitoyennes et de nos concitoyens et
bien d'avoir accès à nos services
publics mais aussi de renforcer les
politiques d'accès à tous les droits ce
que nous menons aujourd'hui à travers le
déploiement de la solidarité à la source
nous avons avons su aussi entendre ce
que nous disaient les différents groupes
d'opposition au-delà du groupe qui
portait cette proposition loi sur le
fait que cette proposition ne viendrait
pas en opposition de la politique
actuellement menée aussi nous nous
orientons vers un vote d'abstention et
j'appellerai mes collègues du groupe
Rennaissance tout à l'heure à s'abstenir
sur ce texte en ayant tout de même une
pensée première bien entendu pour
l'ensemble des agentes des agents de la
fonction publique d'État de la fonction
publique hospitalière de la fonction
publique territoriale qui je le
pense de la fonction publique
européenne de des administrateurs qui
nous accompagnent ici mais en tout cas
qui au quotidien et bien font un travail
exemplaire pour permettre l'accès de nos
concitoyennes et nos concitoyens au
service public dans le respect des
principes de notre République je vous
remercie je vous
remercie la Paro par est à Madame
Grangier pour le groupe rassemblement
national merci madame la Présidente et
bien puisque c'est une soirée dommage et
bien hommage aux services public hommage
aux maisons France service et bien moi
je vais rendre hommage aux assistantes
sociales et aux travailleurs sociaux qui
bien souvent se retrouvent face à des
difficultés parce que justement ils
n'ont plus
d'interlocuteur pour pouvoir discuter
parler des dossiers des personnes qu'il
suivent je veux rendre hommage aussi à
tous les agents qui travaillent dans ces
maisons France service qui sont de
véritaable couteau suisse à qui on
demande toujours plus avec toujours si
peu de moyens voilà et c'est pourquoi
aujourd'hui le groupe rassemblement
national votera en faveur de cette
proposition de loi qui vise à
réinstaurer de l'accueil physique dans
les services publics un véritable accue
physique
merci
merci la parole est à Madame Blin pour
le groupe les républicains merci madame
la Présidente nous sommes attachés à nos
services publics et et je pensais aussi
que la macronie l'était j'avoue
qu'entendre monsieur Gouffier Valante
nous y dire avec une conviction qu'il
s'abstiendra sur un texte qui ne fait
que réaffirmer et je loue cette
initiative de la France insoumise que
nous
soutiendrons réaffirmer que nos
concitoyens ont besoin d'avoir un
accueil physique dans nos villages c'est
être complètement déconnecté de la la
réalité que de nier qu'aujourd'hui il y
a un éloignement il y a clairement un
éloignement encore hier j'étais et je
n'ai pas pu m'exprimer sur l'amendement
rapport parce que vous aviez un certain
nombre de propositions à faire en
matière de rapport par rapport à la
poste j'étais encore hier avec des
facteurs qui faisaient la grève et qui
qui nous explique qu'ils ont une charge
de travail importante qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui ils ne peuvent plus
rendre ce service public au public il y
a une vraie difficulté aujourd'hui et
une vraie déconnexion dans nos villages
dans nos terrains les maisons France
service effectivement résolv un certain
nombre de difficultés certes mais
aujourd'hui la complexité administrative
c'est que parfois un certain nombre de
fonctionnaires queles que soient les
administrations se retrouvent confronté
à des difficultés qu'ils ne peuvent pas
résoudre eux-mêmes donc effectivement
hommage à ces Français qui s'engagent
dans nos services publics et qui font le
maximum pour rendre ce service à nos
concitoyens mais ne fermez pas les yeux
chers collègues parce qu'aujourd'hui les
maisons Fran service n'ont clairement
pas tout résolu dans nos villages et
qu'il y a encore nécessairement besoin
de s'investir sur cette question pour
véritablement avoir une proximité avec
ses services et le
public merci monsieur le Président mat
pour le groupe
démocrate bien moi je je vais reprendre
un petit peu ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure j'ai vu l'évolution de l'accès
au service public en milieu rural je
peux dire que les maisons service sont
une réussite nous avons des
fonctionnaires qui sont présents pour
répondre aux demandes quand vous avez eu
le l'occasion et l'honneur d'assumer la
fonction de maire comme mon cas pendant
16 ans en créant une agence
postale on arrive également nous à
répondre alors moi ce texte pour moi il
est il est pas utile les maisons fr serv
sont util ce texte n'est pas utile ce
texte n'est pas utile parce que tout
simplement j'aimerais qu'on laisse se
développer les maisons Fran service
qu'on laisse les élus de terrain
s'approprier cet outil qui est
remarquable et qu'on se donne
rendez-vous peut-être dans quelques
années c'est beaucoup trop récent voilà
et nous on assumera notre responsabilité
on votera contre ce texte merci s'il
vous plaît mes chers
collègues
très bien
excusez-moi madame Goulet madame Goulet
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît je vous
remercie
merci c'est l'heure du scrutin public
sur le vote de l'ensemble de la
proposition de
loi chacun a regagné sa place le scrutin
est ouvert sur l'ensemble du
texte
[Musique]
le scrutin est
clos chaque chose en son temps s'il vous
plaît votant 188 s'il vous plaît je suis
en train d'annoncer les résultats
bon non attendez attendez j'annonce les
résultats je prendrai le rappel au
règlement je vous ai bien entendu ça
suffit ça
suffit votant 188 exprimés 151 majorité
76 pour 12 contre 29 l'Assemblée
nationale a adopté la proposition de
loi